defamatory implication about mr depp and
number five the defamatory implication
was designed and intended by miss heard
and number six due to the circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication to someone who saw it other
than mr depp and if mr depp further
proved by clear and convincing evidence
number seven that miss heard made the
statement with actual malice if mr depp
failed to prove any one or more of the
seven elements above then you shall find
your verdict for misheard with respect
to the above statement
you shall only return your verdict for
mr depp on his claim for defamation
about the following statement if he has
proved by the greater weight of the
evidence that number one misheard made
or published the following statement i
had the rare vantage point of seeing in
real time how institutions protect men
accused of abuse and number two the
statement was about mr depp and number
three the statement is false
and number four the statement has a
defamatory implication about mr depp and
number five the defamatory implication
was designed and intended by miss heard
and number six due to the circumstances
surrounding the publication of the
statement it conveyed a defamatory
implication to someone who saw it other
than mr depp and if mr depp further
approved by clear and convincing
evidence number seven that miss heard
made the statement with actual malice if
mr depp failed to prove any one or more
of the seven elements above then you
shall find your verdict for misheard
with respect to the above statement
you shall only return your verdict for
misheard on her claim for defamation
about the following statement if she has
proved by the greater weight of the
evidence that number one adam waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made or published the following
statement amber heard and her friends in
the media use fake sexual violence
allegations as both a sword and a shield
depending on their needs they have
selected some of her sexual violence
hoax facts as the sword inflicting them
on the public and mr depp and number two
the statement is about misheard and
number three the statement was seen by
someone other than misheard and number
four the statement is false and if ms
heard further proved by clear and
convincing evidence number five that the
statement by mr waldman was made with
actual malice
if miss heard failed to prove any one or
more of the five elements above then you
shall find your verdict for mr depp with
respect to the above statement
you shall only return your verdict for
misheard on her claim for defamation
about the following statement if she has
proved by the greater weight of the
evidence that number one adam waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made or published the following
statement quite simply this was an
ambush a hoax they set up mr depp up by
calling the cops but the first attempt
didn't do the trick the officers came so
amber and her friend spilled a little
wine and roughed the place up got their
story straight under the direction of a
lawyer and publicist and then place the
second call to 9-1-1 and number two the
statement is about misheard and number
three the statement was seen by someone
other than misheard
and four the statement is false and if
misheard further proved by clear and
convincing evidence number five that the
statement by mr waldman was made with
actual malice if miss heard failed to
prove any one or more of the
the five elements above then you shall
find your verdict for mr depp with
respect to the above statement
you shall only return your verdict for
misheard on her claim for defamation
about the following statement if she has
proved by the greater weight of the
evidence that number one adam waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made or published the following
statement we have reached the beginning
of the end of miss heard's abuse hoax
against johnny depp and number two the
statement is about misheard and number
three the statement was seen by someone
other than misheard and number four the
statement is false and if miss heard
further proved by clear and convincing
evidence number five that the statement
by mr waldman was made with actual
malice if misheard failed to prove any
one or more of the five elements above
then you shall find your verdict for mr
depp with respect to the above statement
when used in these instructions the
phrase the greater weight of the
evidence also sometimes called the
preponderance of the evidence means the
evidence which you find more persuasive
when evaluated against all the evidence
that has been admitted in the case the
testimony of one witness whom you
believe can be the greater weight of the
evidence
when a party has the burden of proving
any issue by clear and convincing
evidence he or she must produce evidence
that creates in your minds a firm belief
or conviction that he or she has proved
the issue
a statement that is not directly
defamatory may nonetheless suggest a
defamatory meaning in an indirect way
that is by implication
in determining whether any of the
statements have a defamatory implication
you must consider the op-ed as a whole
and the circumstances surrounding its
publication you should consider if these
circumstances show that the words used
are defamatory and relate to mr depp
however such circumstances cannot extend
the meaning of the words used in the
op-ed beyond their ordinary and common
meaning the proposed implication must be
reasonably drawn from the words actually
used
in determining whether any of the
statements in the op-ed are false and
defamatory as to mr depp you must read
the statements in the context of the
op-ed as a whole this means you may not
seize on any one word phrase or image or
consider only one particular statement
phrase or passage in isolation
in determining whether any of mr
waldman's statements are false and
defamatory you must read those
statements in context as a whole this
means you may not seize on any one word
phrase or image or consider only one
particular statement phrase or passage
in isolation
both parties have the burden of proving
actual malice by clear and convincing
evidence to meet this burden each party
must prove by clear and convincing
evidence that each statement was made or
published number one with knowledge that
the statement was false or number two so
recklessly as to amount to a willful
disregard for the truth that is with a
high degree of awareness that the
statement was probably false
actual malice is a subjective analysis
that looks to the state of the mind of
the person who made the statement if the
person who made the statement is
believed it was substantially accurate
at the time of its publication then it
does not give rise to liability for
defamation
the term actual malice should not be
confused with the more common meanings
of the word malice such as ill will or
hatred
actual malice is not established merely
because an author was motivated by ill
will prejudice hostility hatred contempt
or even a desire to injure another
in order to find that misheard
republished the original op-ed including
the headline through a tweet on december
19 2018 you must find that she
re-transmitted the defamatory material
or redistributed the material with the
goal of reaching a new audience stated
differently republication occurs when
the speaker has affirmatively reiterated
the statement a hyperlink directing
readers to a previous article on the
same website does not direct the
previous article to a new audience
merely linking to an article does not
amount to republication but adding
content to a linked article may
constitute republication you must
determine whether any added content was
intended to intended to reach a new
audience if you find any content added
to the hyperlink was intended to reach a
new audience it constitutes a
republication
further if you find a republication
occurred on december 19 2018 then in
order to find for mr depp against miss
heard you must also find by clear and
convincing evidence that ms heard made
this republication with actual malice
a principle is a person or legal entity
with power or right to control the means
and methods of performance by which
another person performs the principal's
work an agent is the person who is
subject to the power or right of a
principle to control the means and
methods of performing the work
an attorney has expressed authority to
do everything which the client expressly
authorized him to do and the implied
authority to do everything necessary or
incidental to the purpose for which he
was retained
ms hurd has the burden of proving by the
greater weight of the evidence that mr
waldman was an agent of mr depp that mr
waldman was acting within the scope of
his agency when he made the statements
you must remember that there is no
burden on either party to prove the
truth of any of the statements both
parties were free to offer proof of
truth but by doing so they do not assume
the burden of convincing you of the
truth of the statements the burden
remains on each party to prove that the
statements he or she complains of are
false
the rules of evidence ordinarily do not
permit witnesses to testify as opinions
or conclusions an exception to this rule
exists as to those whom we call expert
witnesses witnesses who by education and
experience have become expert in some
art science profession or calling may
state their opinions as to relevant and
material matters in which they profess
to be expert and may also state their
reasons for the opinion you should
consider each expert opinion receiving
evidence in this case and give it such
weight as you may think it deserves if
you should decide that the opinions on
expert witness is not based upon
sufficient education and experience or
if you should conclude that the reasons
given in support of the opinion are not
sound or if you feel that it is
outweighed by other evidence you may
disregard the opinion entirely
in considering the way to be given to
the testimony of expert witnesses whose
opinions differ you may consider the
ability and character of the witnesses
their actions upon the witness stand the
weight and process of the reasoning by
which they support their opinion their
possible bias in favor of the side for
which they testify the relative
opportunities for study or observation
of the matters about which they testify
and any other matters which serve to
illuminate their statements
in considering the weight to be given to
the testimony of expert witnesses you
should consider the basis for his or her
opinion in the manner by which he or she
arrived at it and the underlying fact
and data upon which he or she relied
an expert witness was asked whether
statements contained in published
treatises periodicals or pamphlets or
reliable authority of a type normally
relied upon by others in his or her
field of expertise this evidence is
permitted to test the knowledge accuracy
and opinions of the expert witness and
if such evidence is established as a
reliable authority by expert testimony
it may be considered by you along with
the other evidence in the case
in considering the evidence you are not
limited to the bald statements of the
witnesses in other words you are not
limited solely to what you see and hear
as the witnesses testify on the contrary
you are permitted to draw from the facts
which you find to have been proven such
reasonable inferences as may seem
justified in the light of your own
experience
during the trial of this case certain
testimony has been presented to you by
way of video depositions you should give
this testimony the same consideration as
to its weight and credibility as you
give to the testimony of witnesses who
testified here in court you must not
discount any testimony merely because it
was shown to you by video recording
when one of the parties testifies
unequivocally to the facts within his or
her own knowledge those statements of
fact and the necessary inferences from
them are binding upon him or her he or
she cannot rely on other evidence in
conflict with his or her own testimony
to strengthen his or her case however
you must consider his or her testimony
as a whole and you must consider a
statement made in one part of his or her
testimony in the light of any
exclamation explanation or clarification
made elsewhere in his or her testimony
any fact that may be proved by direct
evidence may be proved by circumstantial
evidence that is you may draw all
reasonable and legitimate inferences and
deductions from the evidence
if you believe from the case that a
witness other than mr depp or mrs heard
previously made a statement inconsistent
with his or her testimony at this trial
the only purpose for which that
statement may be considered by you is
its bearing on the witness's credibility
it is not evidence that what the witness
previously previously said was true
if you believe from the evidence that
miss heard or mr depp previously made a
statement inconsistent with her or his
testimony at this trial that previous
statement may be considered by you as
evidence that what misheard or mr depp
previously said was true
in reaching your verdict in this case
you are to consider the testimony and
evidence sometimes attorneys stated
objections during the course's trial and
instructed a witness not to answer a
question objections and instructions to
witnesses are not evidence and you may
not consider them in reaching your
verdict nor are you to draw any
inference from the fact that an
objection was made
you must not consider any matter that
was rejected or stricken by the court it
is not evidence and should be discarded
any amount of damages requested by a
party is not evidence in this case you
should not consider it as evidence in
arriving at your verdict
if you find your verdict for mr depp or
misheard then he or she is entitled to
recover compensatory damages without any
proof of actual or pecuniary injury as a
result injury to mr depp or mrs heard's
personal and business reputation
humiliation embarrassment is presumed
if you find either party liable for
defamation then in determining the
actual amount determining the amount of
damages to which the opposing party is
entitled you may take into consideration
all the circumstances surrounding the
defamatory statements the occasions on
which they were made and the extent of
their publication the nature and
character of the insult the probable
effect on those who heard the statements
and their probable and natural effect
upon the defamed party's personal
feelings and upon his or her standing in
the community and in business your
verdict should be for the amount that
will fully and fairly compensate him or
her for number one any loss or injury to
his or her business
number two any insult to him or her
including any pain embarrassment
humiliation or mental suffering
number three any injury to his or her
reputation
and number four any actual out-of-pocket
losses that were caused by the
statements
mr depp cannot recover damages from for
any harm that occurred after november
second two thousand twenty miss hurt can
recover damages for any harm that
occurred after mr waldman's statements
were published
the burden is on the party seeking
damages to prove by the greater weight
of the evidence each item of damages he
or she claims and to prove that each
item was caused by the defamatory
statements at issue neither party is
required to prove the exact amount of
damages but the party must show
sufficient facts and circumstances to
make to permit you to make a reasonable
estimate of each item if either party
fails to do so then he or she cannot
recover for that item
if you have found by clear and
convincing evidence that the statements
in the op-ed were made with knowledge
that they were false or so recklessly as
to amount to a willful disregard for the
truth that is with a high degree of
awareness that the statements were
probably false then you may award
punitive damages punish misheard for
such actions and to serve as an example
to prevent others from making such
statements in the future you must state
separately in your verdict any amount
you allow as compensatory damages if any
and the amount you allow as punitive
damages
if you have bound by clear and
convincing evidence that mr waldman
while acting as an agent for mr depp
made the statements with knowledge that
they were false or so recklessly as to
amount to a willful disregard for the
truth that is with a high degree of
awareness that the statements were
probably false then you may award
punitive damages to punish mr depp for
his such actions and to serve as an
example to prevent others from making
such statements in the future you must
state separately in your verdict any
amount you allow is compensatory damages
if any and the amount you allow is
punitive damages
all right closing arguments
we'll see
there you go
i think so no you had it for a second
good morning
thank you
let's try that again
good morning
on may 27
2016
miss hurd walked into a courthouse in
los angeles california to get a no
notice ex-party restraining order
against mr depp
and in doing so
ruined his life
by falsely telling the world that she
was the survivor of domestic abuse at
the hands of mr depp
today
on may 27
2022
exactly six years later
we ask you to give mr depp his life back
by telling the world that mr death is
not the abuser ms heard said he is
and hold ms heard accountable for her
lies
ladies and gentlemen the jury as you
probably know by now my name is camille
vasquez
on behalf of mr depp and all my
colleagues at brown rednick
i want to thank you deeply
for your time and your service over
these last seven weeks
we understand that it probably has not
been convenient for you to be here every
day
and we are so grateful
for your time and careful consideration
of the evidence as you deliberate
after weeks of sitting in this courtroom
listening to testimony and looking at
evidence now it's time for you
the jury to come to a decision
you have been entrusted with a serious
task
what is at stake in this trial is a
man's good name
even more than that
what is at stake at this trial
is a man's life
the life that he lost when he was
accused of a heinous crime
and the life he could live when he is
finally vindicated
exactly six years ago today
on may 27 2016 miss hurd walked into
court and filed a false report of
domestic abuse against her husband of 15
months johnny depp
the scene was a setup
she tipped off the paparazzi
so they would be waiting
they knew exactly where she would pause
which side of her face to photograph
and the photos captured what she wanted
them to see
the image of a battered woman
what the paparazzi did not know is that
the dark mark on her face mysteriously
appeared six days after last seen mr deb
it was a lie
she knew it
mr depp knew it
and the multiple witnesses you heard
from who saw her that week of may 21
2016 also knew it
but the world only saw what she wanted
them to see
two years later
when promoting the biggest role of her
career
until this trial
ms hurd presented herself to the world
as a public figure representing domestic
abuse
the headline of the op-ed featured the
term sexual violence
even though she had never before accused
her ex-husband of such a heinous crime
ms hurd and her lawyers love to remind
you of how the op-ed did not mention mr
depp by name
but miss heard made sure that there
would be no mistake about who she was
referring to
she inserted
two years ago so the world would
remember the photo of a battered woman
the mark on her face standing outside
the courthouse
and they would once again see mr depp as
the villain
this time in full swing of the metoo
movement
but what was happening behind closed
doors was quite different from what ms
heard presented to the world
the exact opposite in fact
there is a there is an abuser in this
courtroom
but it is not mr deb
and there is a victim of domestic abuse
in this courtroom but it is not misheard
the evidence presented at this trial has
shown that miss heard is in fact the
abuser and mr deb the
abused as you heard from mr depp and
multiple other witnesses that testified
under oath
at this trial
mr depp experienced persistent verbal
physical and emotional abuse
by misheard during their relationship
and when their relationship was over
miss hurt inflicted the greatest and
cruelest injury of all
she publicly and falsely named mr death
as the abuser
miss heard never thought she would be
held accountable
never thought that she would have to
face
her abuser
she never thought she would never she
would have her supposed mountain of
evidence vetted
she never thought that mr depp would
tell you the jury and the world that he
was the real victim of domestic abuse
she said it in her own
that it was a words fight and see what
the see what the jury and judge thing
tell the world johnny tell them johnny
depp i joined up man i'm i'm a victim of
people's domestic violence
you know it's a fair fight it seems how
many people
at the start of this case
mr chu and i stood before you to give
you our opening statements on behalf of
mr depp
during that statement we made promises
to you about what the evidence would
ultimately show at the end of this trial
we've kept those promises
one of those promises we made was that
you would come to understand who miss
heard is
that she is a deeply troubled person
violently afraid of abandonment
desperate for attention and approval
and in her relationship with mr depp she
was violent she was abusive and she was
cruel
you heard from dr shannon kirby who
explained that ms hurd suffers from
borderline personality disorder and
histrionic personality disorder
these are disorders that are
characterized by anger sometimes
uncontrollable and explosive anger
and a powerful sometimes desperate need
for attention acceptance and approval
fear of abandonment is the deepest fear
a person with these disorders will
suffer from dramatically fluctuating
moods and can sometimes be violent and
aggressive
they can also be charming and likeable
but they can be incredibly manipulative
and wild
an emotional rollercoaster with wild
swings from idolizing their partner
to devaluing him
in fact you saw that
when she completed testing with her own
forensic psychology expert dr don hughes
miss heard self-reported that she felt
like she had three or four different
personalities and that sometimes her
temper would explode and she'd
completely lose control
you heard from multiple witnesses that
misheard can be very pleasant even
charming
but you also heard from multiple
witnesses and in audio recordings of
misheard that she can be incredibly
aggressive
violent and cruel
you heard that even from her former
assistant kate james
miss james testified that ms hurd would
scream
yell and send her barrages of text
messages
in fact mr testified that miss
miss james testified that ms heard
literally spat in her face
you heard from miss heard's former best
friend rocky pennington that miss heard
once hit her when miss pennington did
not do her best to meet miss heard's
needs
you also heard from beverly leonard
that she once witnessed miss heard
assault her then partner in seattle
airport in 2009.
and you heard from mr depp
that miss heard used her sister whitney
as a punching bag
literally and figuratively
you also heard overwhelming evidence
from mr depp and the people that were
around him and misheard during their
relationship
that mr depp suffered persistent verbal
and physical abuse at the hands of
misheard
you've ex heard evidence from dr curry
and the fact witnesses at this trial
that ms heard's deepest fear is one of
abandonment
being left by mr depp
mr death's greatest crime in her mind
the fault she confronts him with time
and time again is that he splits
he leaves the fight especially when miss
heard gets physical
and she couldn't stand it when he did
you heard from miss her yourselves
in audio recordings how upsetting it was
to her when mr depp was split
anytime anything goes wrong
it's like it's your first thing
and it's unnecessary it's not always uh
you're splitting because there's blows
or because there's yelling or anything
you split
many most times when i'm still speaking
in this volume
and nothing has been thrown or hit or
anything
you saw the barrage of text messages she
would send when he would leave calling
him a monster for doing so
you heard from witnesses like travis
mcgivern tara roberts and debbie lloyd
that miss heard would clawed mr depp
block the elevator
throw a punch when mr dutt tried to
separate himself from the fight
and you heard from mr depp and mister's
couple therapist dr anderson that miss
heard reported that when mr depp would
leave to de-escalate a fight she would
strike him to keep him there because she
would rather be in a fight than have him
leave
you heard from mr depp about how often
miss heard would berate him insult him
and physically attack him including one
of the most serious occasions when
misheard threw a vodka bottle at mr deb
severely injuring his finger and then it
put a cigarette out on his face
you heard from mr depp that this whole
incident in australia started because
miss heard was enraged that mr depp
wanted a post-nuptial agreement and she
wasn't in his will
just a month after getting married
when her husband was seriously injured
and bleeding from a partially amputated
finger what did miss her do
she pursued him
she kept coming after him because that's
what she does
she wouldn't stop
at least
five bathrooms and two bedrooms i went
to
two to
avoid talking to me to escape them
to escape the fight you don't escape the
fight you escape the solution you escape
the solution you escape figuring it out
we cannot work it out if you run away to
the bathroom every time
you heard mr depp testify he went
through something like a nervous
breakdown that day
and he wrote a lot of things on mirrors
in other places
again what did miss heard do as her
husband was bleeding from serious injury
she wrote snarky messages right back to
him
she denied it under oath to you but the
evidence you saw speaks for itself
you heard from mr deaf security sean
bett who was aware of constant arguing
and bickering he witnessed miss hurd
calling mr deaf names
fat ass
[ __ ] you johnny
mr bett testified that he saw
undocumented injuries on mr deck
a swollen eyelid in march of 2015 cuts
on his nose scratch marks on his chin in
december of 2015.
and you heard from travis mcgivern who
testified the misheard called mr depp
names like washed up
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and worst of all
a [ __ ] deadbeat dad
miss heard would take the low blows and
hit him where it hurts his children
mr mcgivern told you that on march 23rd
2015 ms heard through things that mr deb
spatted him and ultimately punched him
in the face leaving him with a shiner
you heard testimony from malcolm
connolly another security member who
testified he saw miss heard throw things
in mr depp
a cigarette lighter on a plane
a soda can from upstairs at the eastern
columbia building he never saw marx on
misheard
but he saw marks on mr depp
scratches bruises on his left eye
scratches on his left ear
and he took pictures documenting entries
like this one
you also heard from tara roberts a
manager at mr depp's island who
witnessed miss heard telling mr deb that
he was washed up and would die fat and
lonely
you also heard from miss roberts that
she witnessed miss heard clawing and
grabbing at mr depp grabbing his hair
trying to pull him back to her and mr
depp had a visible injury to his nose on
that occasion
most importantly you heard from miss
heard yourselves
on multiple audio recordings admitting
to being physically violent with mr depp
you heard ms hurd admit to hitting mr
dap
and then you [ __ ] claw
i i remember hating you as a response to
the door thing
and i'm really sorry about hitting you
with the door of it or hitting your head
i did not mean to nor you didn't mean to
hit me in the head with the door but you
meant to i didn't mean the jaw i meant
to hit you and i
i did not do this thing with the door i
do remember i did mean to hit you with
that you didn't mean
the door no god no i didn't
punch him in the air
i didn't okay i'm sorry i hate you i
didn't mean to hate you but it was in
response i just reacted in response to
my foot i just reacted
you heard her admit it again and claim
mr depp was a baby for complaining about
the abuse
and i watched you lie and then i didn't
punch you by the way you i'm sorry that
i didn't
uh uh hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you it was not punching you
they you're not punched don't tell me
what it feels like to be punched you
know you've been a lot of fights been
around a long time i know yeah when you
[ __ ] have a closure you didn't get
punched you got hit i'm sorry i hit you
like this but i did not punch you i did
not [ __ ] deck you i [ __ ] was
hitting you i don't know what the motion
of my actual hand was but you're fine i
did not hurt you i did not punch you i
was hitting you how are you how what am
i supposed to do do this
i'm not sitting here bitching about it
am i you are that's the difference
between me and you you're a [ __ ] baby
because you started you are such a baby
girl the [ __ ] up johnny physical fights
i did start a physical fight you did so
because
yes you did so you did the right thing
the big thing the you know what you are
admirable
take a minute to really think about what
you just heard there
quote i'm sorry that i didn't hit you
across the face in a proper slap but i
was hitting you
i was not punching you
babe you're not punched
imagine that was mr depp saying not to
misheard on that recording
let's play one more
[Laughter]
no
no no you're right
[Laughter]
oh
what else what else other things do you
want to add
you [ __ ] lie
oh no i want to know
get out your uber you're gonna wait
come on go be a real married man deal
with your [ __ ] the way that a man does
go run to the next house
every man does
this is the real misheard
the one in the audio recordings
not the one you saw in this courtroom
what you didn't hear on a single
recording you heard in this case
and there were many played by both
parties is mr depp ever admitting to
hitting
punching or kicking misheard
you didn't hear it
it doesn't exist
it didn't happen
and despite the fact that mr deaf and
misheard are heard discussing many of
the alleged incidents you've heard about
at this trial like australia and the
bahamas
you never heard miss heard accuse mr
depp of sexual assault
unlike mr depp who you heard admit to
and own up to his past mistakes and his
struggles particularly with drugs and
alcohol
miss heard will not admit that she has
never done that she has ever done
anything wrong
but she cannot deny what you heard on
those recordings
as much as miss heard and her lawyers
have tried to make this case about mr
depp's language
it is misheard that repeatedly admits to
violence
by april and may of 2016
mr depp had reached his limit his mother
was dying
his finances were a mess
and when he showed up late to miss
herd's 30th birthday party because a
meeting with his new business manager
edward white
had gone late miss heard of course was
not understanding she was furious
you heard from mr death both in this
courtroom and on audio recordings that
misheard punched him that evening
he left with travis mcgivern and the
next morning he learned that someone had
left feces
on his bed
misheard denies responsibility but she
admitted to the prank to starling
jenkins you heard him testify to that
effect
for almost a month after that they
didn't see each other
and you heard from mr depp that when his
mother died
on may 20th 2016 he resolved to leave
miss heard he was done
and when miss heard learned that mr depp
was done that she was really losing him
she went on the attack
she filed for divorce before mr depp
could
then as you heard from mr deaf's divorce
lawyer laura wasser ms heard sent a
letter demanding financial support
and when her demands weren't met
misheard struck a blow against mr depp
that was more damaging than any physical
blow she had ever landed
when she walked into court
six years ago today on may 27 2016 to
get a domestic violence restraining
order against mr depp she did so in
front of paparazzi with a mark on her
face
the evidence presented at this trial
demonstrates that miss her didn't just
want a divorce
she wanted to ruin him
ms heard denied alerting tmz to the tro
filing in this courtroom
but you heard testimony from morgan
tremaine that tmz knew to go to the
courthouse
knew what side of her face the alleged
bruise was on and that mr would pause
she would pause
for paparazzi
who got the photos that ended up
splashed across newspapers and magazines
mr testified that she did not personally
give photographs of her apparent
injuries to people magazine
but somehow these pictures that she took
and maintained on her devices ended up
on the cover of people magazine one
month later
in the end she walked away with seven
million dollars without any tax
liabilities which she said she was
donating to two charities
the aclu and the children's hospital of
los angeles
the aclu
they got less than a million dollars
from her
and the children's hospital
they got 250 000
but that didn't stop miss heard from
telling the world that she donated
everything because remember she wanted
nothing
and she had donated everything the word
donated
and that didn't stop her from testifying
under the penalty of perjury that she
had donated it
miss her tried to tell you that pledge
and donate mean the same thing
she claims she hasn't given the money
because she was sued
but you've heard on
contested evidence that she has the
money for 13 months prior to this
lawsuit being commenced by mr depp
she had all the money
and had month after month after month to
fulfill her pledge and actually donate
the money
but she didn't
she also told you that she never
fulfilled the pledge because mr deb sued
her for defamation that's a blatant lie
it was misheard who fired the first shot
after the divorce was finalized when she
sought to initiate an arbitration
against mr depp for defamation three
months before the op-ed
was even published and six months
before mr depp filed this lawsuit
not only does this contradict ms hurd's
excuse for not making donations
it contradicts her narrative that she
just wants to move on with her life
that she just wants mr depp to leave her
alone
lies
that is misheard's narrative lies upon
lies
danish
video there and actually were all kinds
of accusations uh flying your way when
you said all this and then there was a
divorce settlement you got seven million
dollars people were saying this is all
about the money but then you did
something that uh twisted that whole
argument what did you do with that money
seven
million dollars in total was donated to
i split it between the aclu and
children's hospital of los angeles clu
is a human rights organization aclu is a
prominent
organization nonprofit organization in
the united states it's called the
american civil liberties union and they
work on behalf of marginalized
communities
on the ground and legislative reform
and more power to you because that's
that's something that i've never wanted
nothing
when you catch miss heard in a lie she
tries to cover it up with more lies
so let's talk about the giant lie at the
heart of this case
miss herd's claim that mr depp is an
abusive monster
and that she is a public figure
representing domestic abuse
at the start of this case mr chu and i
told you that you are going to hear some
disturbing and graphic tales of abuse
from misheard
and they were designed to shock you and
overwhelm you
which you have
we told you that this would be a
performance the role of her lifetime
as a heroic survivor survivor of brutal
abuse
when mr dutt brought this case for
defamation miss heard went all in
she spun a story of shocking
overwhelming brutal abuse
she came into this courtroom prepared to
give the performance of her life and she
gave
it misheard miss herd's acting coach
christina sexton testified that miss
heard has difficulty crying when she is
acting
you saw it
misheard sobbing without tears
while spinning elaborate exaggerated
fantastical accounts of abuse
and everything going on in her mind
almost a decade prior while enduring
that abuse
it was a performance
she told you that what she thinks about
excuse me she told you what she thinks
you need to hear to convict this man as
a domestic abuser and a rapist
she wants you to believe that she was
abused countless times
countless times
over the entire course of their
relationship
but as mr chu and i promised you the
evidence just does not bear that out
miss heard has told you that she has
mountains of evidence of abuse
but there are no medical records
reflecting she sustained any injuries
from the abuse she claims
ms hurd had medical professionals at her
disposal
dr kipper debbie lloyd her own nurse
erin felotti
and yet there is nothing
miss her took pictures all the time
pictures of mr depp sleeping
pictures of
cocaine
pictures of property damage
pictures of herself
as an actress she was photographed all
the time
where are the pictures of the horrific
injuries ms heard describes
ms hurd also took audio recordings and
videos frequently
where are the videos of mr depp
attacking her
where are the audio recordings of mr
depp admitting to or apologizing for
physical abuse
there are none
what ms heard has and what you've seen
multiple times is a video of mr depp
banging some cabinets around in a
kitchen
a video that based on the testimony you
heard from morgan tremaine the former
tmz employee miss heard seems to have
sold to tmz right before she was deposed
in connection with her divorce from mr
depp
sure ms heard can point to text messages
where mr depp is apologizing to her but
never for violence
mr council showed you defendants exhibit
325
where mr depp says sorry for quote my
behavior i'm a [ __ ] savage
but this is not an apology for physical
violence it's an apology for the quote
these heinous slinging insults
mr depp is apologizing for the words he
used
unlike miss heard who you heard
apologizing for physical violence in
multiple audio recordings you have never
heard that from mr depp
because he never used physical violence
against miss heard
miss her told you that mr depp started
abusing her right from the very
beginning of her relationship starting
at the beginning of 2012
but she has repeatedly testified under
oath
differently to having spent a year of
bliss with mr depp
before he ever laid a hand on her
and now
now in this courtroom
she has suddenly erased an entire year
of magic
she wants you to believe that instead of
hitting her after a year of magic mr
depp was hitting her immediately
the good times she has testified to
about repeatedly in the past apparently
never happened
and with the good times erased
ms hurd wants you to believe that she
gave mr depp a big knife
that said
hasta la muerte
until death
to the man who supposedly would get
drunk and high
and beat her
miss hurt admitted to you during this
trial that mr deb always wears big
chunky rings on every finger
according to her he was wearing these
rings when he'd slap her
hit her
punch her in the face
but you have not seen a scene a single
photograph
that reflects serious injuries miss
heard would have sustained if this was
true
not one
mister testified to an incident in march
2013 when mr adept supposedly hit her
multiple times in the face while wearing
rings
and this is what her face looked like
afterwards
miss her testified to an incident in
russia
where she claims mr depp whacked her in
the face and gave her a bloody nose
she didn't take pictures of her bloody
nose
but her photograph was taken on that
trip and this is what she looked like
miss her told you that there was an
incident the night of the met gala in
may 2014 when mr depp supposedly whacked
miss her in the face
leaving her with a red discolored and
slow swollen nose that she felt
was broken
miss heard didn't show you any
photographs of these alleged injuries
the photographs were taken of her the
following night and there were no
visible injuries to ms heard's face
it's her testified that in january 2015
while she and mr depp were in tokyo mr
depp knelt on her back so aggressively
that she was concerned that bruises
would be visible in her backless dress
here's miss hurt in that backless dress
miss her testified that after an
incident december 2015
she had two black eyes a broken nose and
chunks of hair missing
the assault was allegedly so violent
that there was blood left all over the
pillows
and mr depp had broken the bed frame
pictures were taken of that bed frame
and in that picture there appears to be
a pocket knife on the bed
and that picture fails to capture the
bloody pillows
and here is what ms hurd looked like on
the james corden show the next day
indeed you heard from miss heard's own
nurse erin fellotti that she saw her a
day or two afterwards and could not
visualize the injuries ms heard
described
miss heard did take pictures of herself
after this alleged incident
but are the injuries reflected in these
photographs consistent
that's the question are they consistent
with the brutal assault and serious
injuries ms heard has testified to
or are these injuries more consistent
with mr depp's testimony that he and
miss heard bumped heads while he was
trying to restrain ms hurd
to keep her from attacking him
out of australia
where mr depp sustained the most serious
injury from his relationship with miss
heard ms heard spun a story of horror
a three-day ordeal with drug with a drug
field mr depp violently assaulting her
cutting his own finger off dragging her
through glass and then bending her
back over a counter and raping her with
a whiskey bottle
she claimed that she had bruises on her
face
cuts all over her arms and feet and was
bleeding from her vagina from the sexual
assault
and what did miss heard say she did she
went upstairs
took some sleeping pills and went to
sleep
the next morning she took pictures of
the mirrors her husband had written on
in paint using his amputated finger
she took no pictures of herself
her alleged injuries
or the proper
property damage she testified to in this
courtroom
when malcolm connolly jerry judge
dr kipper and nurse debbie lloyd arrived
to extract mr depp and get him medical
treatment for his finger injury
you heard from mr connolly dr kipper and
miss lloyd all of them testified they
did not observe any injuries to misheard
and no one including miss heard
testified that she sought medical
treatment
you also heard from ben king
he also saw misheard right after this
alleged incident he flew home with her
to los angeles
he testified that mr didn't want to
leave that she said i can't leave i
can't leave it will be the end if i
leave
he also testified that once they did
leave for los angeles ms hurd asked him
if he ever got so mad he just lost it
when miss hurt arrived in los angeles
she saw travis mcgivern who also
testified he observed no injuries
and her personal nurse erin felati who
documented no requests for medical
treatment and no injuries in her nursing
notes from his heard
you heard from mr death's sister christy
that she also saw miss heard when she
arrived back to los angeles and observed
no injuries on misheard
christie testified that when she told
miss heard her fighting with mr depp was
unsustainable miss heard responded that
christy should get off her cross
that mr depth liked her feisty
mister's testimony about what occurred
in australia just doesn't add up
that's because there was a monster in
that house in australia but it wasn't mr
depp it was misheard
other than miss herd's testimony all the
evidence you've seen in this trial shows
that it was misheard who attacked
and grievously wounded mr depp when she
threw a vodka bottle at him severing his
finger
mr depp told dr kipper that when dr
kipper arrived to treat mr jeff's finger
you've seen the pictures of the bar area
in australia with the broken vodka
bottles on the ground and trails of
blood drops on the floor and a bloody
tissue on the floor
you've heard from ben king that the tip
of mr depp's finger was found in the
same bar area
and you heard from dr gilbert that the
injury to mr jeff's finger could have
been caused exactly as he described
and interestingly you heard from
christina sexton that miss heard told
her that mr depp injured his finger
while swinging a bottle around
not smashing a phone as miss heard
surmised in this courtroom but swinging
a bottle around
you also heard from ms sexton that miss
heard first told her about the bottle
rape in australia while miss sexton was
at miss herd's home
meeting with her lawyers
the day before miss sexton was scheduled
to be deposed in this case
the evidence presented at this trial
shows that this is not the only time
that mr disclosed a sexual assault at a
convenient time for purposes of
litigation she's involved in
the first time that's heard claimed that
mr depp sexually assaulted her in the
bahamas in december 2015 was after tara
roberts the manager of mr depp's island
submitted a sworn statement in the uk
action describing the incident she
testified to in this courtroom
where miss heard chased mr depp out of
the house was yelling and then pleading
with mr deb to stay while clawing at his
hair and clothes
and left mr dip with an injury to his
face
that's the first time she disclosed it
after there was contrary evidence
ms heard testified about another
incident just two weeks after the events
in australia
where mr depp supposedly attacked ms
heard and almost pushed her sister
whitney down the stairs
whitney is the only witness that you
heard from that backs up miss heard's
version of events
she's it
and the only witness other than miss
heard who claims to have seen mr depp
physically attack misheard
but just like ms hurd's version of the
events in australia her testimony about
the staircase incident and that of her
sister whitney's just doesn't square up
with the other evidence in this trial
their testimony is contradicted by the
testimony of travis mcgivern and debbie
lloyd who were there that night
miss heard and whitney testified that mr
depp threw a red bull can that hit or
almost hit miss lloyd
miss lloyd testified that never happened
mr mcgivern testified that it was
misheard who threw a can at mr depp
mister testified that whitney was
between her and mr death when she
punched him
mr mcgivern testified that he was the
one between miss heard and mr depp when
miss heard punched mr depp
mitheard testified that mr depp was able
to get his hands in her hair
yank her and then hit her in the face
with the cast he had on
but you heard from miss lloyd and dr
colbert mr death's medical doctor who
treated mr depp's finger injury that mr
death's finger was in a delicate state
he had a pin in his finger a skin graft
and a soft cast that immobilized mr
depp's two middle fingers
and tellingly
the only picture of an injury from this
incident
is of mr death
with a shiner
and then we have may 21st
2016.
mister testified that mr depp threw a
phone at her face causing a visible
injury
ms hurd has shown you pictures she
claims to show this injury
but these photographs are not to be
trusted
you heard from mr dumeister that like
many of the photographs ms heard has
presented in this case these photos were
stored in a photo editing application
and these photos show signs of
manipulation
these two photographs were taken at the
exact same time and have the exact same
file name
but they are visually different
one shows significantly more redness on
miss herd's face than the other which
doesn't show any injury at all
mister testified the difference
is explained by turning on a light
but there is no way miss heard could
have taken a picture
turned on a light and then taken another
picture with every hair in the exact
same place within the same second
it's impossible
moreover you heard from multiple
witnesses including officer melissa
signs
officer tyler hadden
and officer william gatlin
isaac baroosh
alejandro romero
whose psalm is heard on or after may
21st
and saw no injuries to her face before
she showed up to that courthouse with a
mark on may 27th
and the very next day after miss heard
walked into court with what appeared to
be a bruise on her face to obtain a
domestic violence restraining order
against mr deb
ms hurd was photographed laughing with
her best friend fresh-faced with no
bruise on her face
the mountain of evidence that mr deaf
abused misheard is simply not there
what we have is a mountain of unproven
allegations that are wild
over the top and implausible
and you can't pick and choose which of
these wild allegations to believe and
which ones to disregard
you either believe all of it or none of
it
either mr depp sexually assaulted
misheard with a bottle in australia
or misheard god up on that stand
in front of all of you
and made up that horrific tale of abuse
either she's a victim of truly horrific
abuse
or she is a woman who is willing to say
absolutely anything
it is disturbing to think that ms hurd
would make up the horrific tales of
abuse that she testified to in this
courtroom
but this case doesn't come down to
whether you believe miss heard or you
believe mr depp this case comes down to
whether you believe miss heard
or you believe
mr depp
christy dombrowski
sean bett
malcolm connolly
travis mcgivern
starling jenkins
keenan wyatt
dr kipper
nurses debbie lloyd and erin felati
tara roberts
ben king
kate james
kate moss
dr colber
morgan knight
morgan tremaine
officers melissa signs
officers tyler hadden
officer william gatlin
and beverly leonard
what ms heard testified to in this
courtroom is the story of far too many
women
but the overwhelming evidence
and weight of that evidence shows that
it's not her story
it's not miss heard's story
it was an act of profound cruelty not
just to mr depp but to true survivors of
domestic abuse
for miss heard to hold herself out as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse
it was false
it was defamatory and it caused
irreparable harm
and to talk more about that i'm going to
turn it over to my colleague and my
friend mr
so
thank you camille logistics are not our
strong suit
and thanks to all of you truly
for taking so much time over these last
several weeks to listen to mr depp
to his friends to his family
and to so many others who have come
forward physically
in this courtroom some from a very long
distance
to tell you the truth
and to finally after so many years
to correct the record
as ms vasquez said
you have now come to know the real amber
heard
scary
we also told you at the start of this
trial that you were going to come to
know the real johnny depp
not
the many characters you've seen him play
so wonderfully in the movies but the man
himself
we kept that promise
you've met the real johnny depp
you have heard that mr depp came from
humble very difficult beginnings
you have heard from mr depp's big sister
who's here in the courtroom today
christy dembrosky
who told you how mr
depp grew up in a deeply troubled
household with the mother betty sue who
was physically abusive
and mentally cruel
as ms dombrowski testified
one of the names that betty sue called
mr depp when he was a little boy was one
eye
because he had to wear an eye patch for
some time
his mother used to hit his father and
the kids including
young mr depp
and when his mother got violent mr depp
would retreat and find a place to hide
sometimes he and his sister christy
would find a place to hide together
mr depp never hit back and like his
father
he either stood up and took the violence
or he retreated from it
those are habits he returned to later
when he found himself in a relationship
with another person who returned his
love with abuse with physical abuse
and despite this long unhappy history
with his mother
johnny never turned his back on her in
her elder years
mr depp moved his mother
to california
and he moved her to los angeles right
across the street from his house so his
two children could get to know her
he hired nurses for his mother
he made sure to take care of her and to
make her comfortable
she never went to hospice she had the
nurses
make her comfortable to the day she died
and from those humble and difficult
beginnings
mr depp grew into one of the greatest
actors and movie stars of his generation
now he came to los angeles with his
first love as a young man planning to be
a musician
music had been a part of his life ever
since he found peace himself in his room
as a young boy
when he was escaping and he would learn
he learned to play the guitar and would
use it as sauce
but it was an actor as his star began
its rise
as he appeared in films too many to
mention including of course his iconic
role as captain jack sparrow and the
pirates of the caribbean franchise
fame came with challenges to mr depp and
his family it was a strange experience
for a shy young man from kentucky to be
thrust into the limelight pursued by
paparazzi
and to have even his very name become a
brand
but he did his best to live a private
quiet life and despite it all and over
the years built a
reputation
as a respected artist and as a decent
very well liked man which you've heard
from many people
mr depp dated major figures like winona
ryder
kate moss
and vanessa paradis with whom he spent
14 years together and with whom they had
their children
before amber heard ladies and gentlemen
no woman ever
no woman ever before amber heard ever
claimed that mr depp raised a hand to
her in his 58 years
and no other woman since
miss heard made that false claim back on
may 17 may 27 2016
has and repeated it in her december 2018
op-ed
has any woman come forward since
this is me too
without any me too
to the contrary ladies and gentlemen you
heard kate moss two days ago testify
this is a woman who has never
testified in any proceeding
ever
a very private person
testified that mr depp never abused her
and that miss heard lied to you and she
lied to you twice
when she told you your honor that
miss
sure
ladies and gentlemen as i was saying
ms heard lied to you twice
when she suggested to you that mr depp
pushed kate moss down the stairs
you told her you heard her say
just two days ago
that
mr depp never did that
and he never hit her and he never
kicked her
that was one objection your honor that's
not what she testifies exactly to
discuss that
thank you honor
they're still at it
ms hurd and her lawyers have spent
much of this trial talking about drugs
and alcohol
mr depp is no saint
and he has never claimed to be one he
has made mistakes in his life as we all
have yes he has struggled with drugs and
alcohol but you never heard him deny
that we told you that in the opening
statement
he owns his flaws he admits to them he
told you all about them
but he is not a violent abuser he's not
abuser as ms heard claims
and he did not and does not deserve to
have his life his legacy
destroyed
by a vicious lie and this is as ms
vasquez said this is the sixth
anniversary of
that there is a world of difference
between having substance abuse
problems and being a physical abuser
ms heard falsely accused mr depp
of beating her that was her first
allegation and you know why and you know
that wasn't true
then
years
years after the fact for the first time
she accused him of raping her
the lies have grown and metastasized
over time
and they need to be stopped
and those
false accusations have caused more harm
to mr depp than her fists ever did
and make no mistake miss heard has
admitted unlike mr depp
ms heard has admitted on the audio tapes
you've heard of this trial and this
vasquez displayed you a a few of them
she has admitted repeatedly
to
physically abusing
mr depp and i would just like to take a
minute to talk about the harm
to mr depp and his family
you have heard
from several of the people in mr depp's
life about the damage ms hurd's lives
have done to him you heard from his
sister christie
who told you how hard it has been on his
family and on her little brother
personally
you heard from mr depp's friend of four
decades and that speaks volumes about mr
dapp he has lifetime friends who appear
for him
mr baruch told you
how mr depp and his family had been
quote completely wrecked unquote by ms
herd's lies
you heard mr depp testify
that he has lost nothing
less than everything because of ms
heard's lies
nothing
less than everything
you heard about mr depp's children
jack and lily rose his children have had
to hear these allegations since 2016
and then that when that started to die
down
they had to hear them again
this time
in december 2018 this time
in the washington post which is national
and international
publication
and mr depp has had to live with the
knowledge that his children will keep
hearing those false rumors and
statements
against him
mr depp has millions of fans people who
have who
grew up watching him on 21
jump street which is something you heard
miss heard mock on one of the tapes that
was played to you
or they grew up watching him play the
swashbuckling pirate captain jack
sparrow in the pirates of the caribbean
movies or willy wonka
mr depp means something to those people
and those people mean a lot
to mr duff
he's a fond memory from childhood or
adolescence or adulthood
and to tarnish him
as an abuser
is to destroy him in the eyes of many of
these people who will never look at him
the same way again
and because of what miss heard
did and because of what she said
mr depp will go to his grave knowing
matter knowing no matter what he does
no matter the outcome of this trial
there are people who used to look up to
him who now believe that he beat a woman
which is the worst thing you can say
about a man
beyond the personal and emotional
effects of misheard's lies
their impact on mr depp and his family
the damage she inflicted on his
reputation and career is undeniable
there's an old saying that a good
reputation takes a lifetime to build
but only a second to destroy
mr depp spent in fact a lifetime
building his reputation as one of the
greatest actors and movie stars of his
generation an iconic figure respected
through and liked throughout hollywood
and recognized and admired throughout
the world
you heard evidence from jack wiggum who
was here today mr depp's agent who
explained that mr depp quote was very
well regarded and respected by peers in
the artistic community unquote and you
heard further testimony from mr wiggum
that mr depp had a deal with disney to
play captain jack sparrow in the sixth
movie sequel of the pirates of the
caribbean
uh franchise
for 22.5
million
but
as mr wiggum explained all of that
changed when miss heard published
her op-ed in december of 2018 in the
washington post quoting from the
testimony you heard by mr wiggum quote
after the op-ed it was impossible to get
him a studio film which is what we
normally would have focused on in that
time period unquote
another quote it was on the damage the
impact of this op-ed as opposed to the
other stories that you you saw the other
publications
mr wiggum explained why this one was so
damaging quote it was a first-person
account i mean from the victim
it's extremely impactful you know with
respect to johnny it was catastrophic
because it was coming from a first
person account
it was not from a journalist it was
coming from someone observing it was
from someone saying this happened to me
unquote you also heard from richard
marks an expert in the inner workings of
hollywood and the entertainment industry
who explained that the impact of miss
herd's allocations on mr depp was
devastating quote it's devastating
it's the type of claim the metoo claim
of sexual violence
domestic abuse that has canceled a list
of actors unquote
and for many and mr depp would agree
with this rightfully so
metoo is an important movement
a movement that mr depp supports and
believes in
it's for true survivors
of abuse not misheard
true victims need protection and true
true perpetrators
need to face the repercussions
but as you've heard in this case
amber heard is not
a true victim and mr depp certainly is
not an abuser
again
nobody has come out of the woodwork to
say me too this is the unique and
singular me too case where there's not a
single me too in fact to the contrary
kate moss who was in a romantic
relationship with mr depp for three
years which he broke up came forward
to say
no
he never pushed her down any stairs
and you heard doug banya an expert in
internet and social media analytics
testified to the impact that ms hurd's
allegations had on mr depp's popularity
ms heard's lawyers tried to tell you
that all of the damage done to mr depp's
career
was because of his own
behavior because he was
sometimes unprofessional or sometimes
late to set but that doesn't hold up
mr depp has been a major figure in
hollywood for decades yes mr depp was
late to set sometimes
but as mr as richard marks testified
quote when you hire johnny depp you get
all of johnny depp which includes being
linked unquote keenan wyatt who has
worked for decades as a sound engineer
on some of mr depp's
films said much the same thing and by
the way mr white is not and never has
been an employee of mr depp he's just
worked with him on on movies
mr depp wasn't canceled by hollywood
because he was sometimes late to set
he was cancelled because
ms heard falsely accused him
of domestic violence and sexual violence
on the pages of the washington post on
december 18 2018 repeating the prior
lies of may 17 2016.
and as you saw at trial ms heard
published the op-ed on december 18 2018
two years
after her public allegations of domestic
abuse
ms heard's publication of the op-ed
coincided with the release of her major
movie aquaman that december and it
coincided as well with her announcement
on twitter
that she was becoming an aclu ambassador
for women's rights
and in that op-ed
ms heard repeated her false allegations
against
mr depp
now she didn't mention his name
she didn't have to
everyone
knew exactly who and what ms heard was
talking about
ms heard got on the stand and tried to
tell you that the op-ed was not about mr
deb
she then said well
it wasn't just about mr deb
but she couldn't deny
and this was yesterday that this was at
least partly about mr deb
the op-ed obviously is about mr depp
and the testimony at trial proves that
you will recall testimony from the
aclu's representative
an attorney
stating that mr depp's name was included
in drafts of the op-ed and that they and
others understood that the op-ed
was about mr depp
specifically the aclu representative
testified among other things quote
based on my review of prior drafts of
the op-ed i knew that they were that she
was referring to johnny depp and the
marriage unquote
ms heard's claim that the op-ed is not
about mr depp
is just another one of her many many
lies in fact what you have seen time and
time again through the course of this
trial
is that misheard lies she lies all the
time about things that are important and
that things that aren't important she
just can't seem to stop and as ms
vasquez said
what she routinely does
is she doesn't take ownership or
responsibility
for anything
and she has an excuse for
everything but in this courtroom
confronted with the evidence she can't
run away from her own words
as my colleague said
words matter
and miss heard is condemned
by her own words so tom let's please
take a look at the words she used in her
op-ed which is plaintiff's exhibit one
and which
ms heard published in december 2018
two years after she first publicly
accused mr depp of being an abuser on
may 27 2016.
the title of the op-ed reads as you can
see quote amber heard i spoke up against
sexual violence and faced our culture's
wrath
that has to change unquote
below that ms heard states
quote then two years ago i became a
public figure representing domestic
abuse and i felt the full force of our
culture's wrath for women who speak out
unquote
and below that
ms heard states quote i had the rare
vantage point of seeing in real time
how institutions protect men accused of
abuse unquote
each of those statements clearly refers
to ms heard's allegations against mr
depp
and taken collectively their message and
their implication
about mr depp is clear
i.e that miss heard is a survivor of
domestic abuse and that mr depp is a
perpetrator
the context
in the rest of the
op-ed makes that clear as well
consider for instance this line quote
imagine a powerful man as a ship
like the titanic
that ship is a huge enterprise
when it strikes an iceberg there are a
lot of people on board desperate to
patch up holes
not because they believe in or even care
about the ship but because their own
fates depend upon the enterprise unquote
everyone in hollywood knew
and everyone in this courtroom now knows
exactly what ms heard intended those
words to mean
the ship the titanic is is mr depp
and ms hurd was the iceberg that sank
him
that's precisely
what
is heard was saying in the op-ed
and in just the same way everyone in
hollywood knew and else hollywood and
elsewhere knew exactly what ms heard
meant by the words quote two years ago
i became a public figure representing
domestic abuse unquote
that was a clear reference
to the day
two years earlier on may 27 2016.
and as ms vasquez said that was six
years to the day that's when his life
ended that was six years ago to this day
when miss heard on may 27 2016 walked
into court
with her public with her publicist jody
gottlieb
having tipped off tmz
with an alleged mark on her face to
accuse mr depp
of abuse
as always as always miss herd was quite
mindful of her image she was careful to
portray herself as the innocent
representative of abuse survivors and by
implication mr depp as the perpetrator
of domestic abuse she was the woman who
in the words of her title supposedly
quote spoke up against sexual violence
unquote
now ms hurd has done a lot to try to
walk away from the title in particular
that's true to form
she has testified that she didn't write
it and she will argue later that she
shouldn't be held liable because she
didn't write it
but as the court's instructions which
you heard this morning make clear
miss heard didn't have to personally
write any part of the op-ed for her to
defame
mr depp through implication
in the washington post
and let's please tom
turn to plaintiff's exhibit three
miss heard as you all can see on the
screen
retweeted the article including the
title on her twitter page
ms heard put her name on it
and she proudly declared quote today i
published this op-ed in the washington
post
ellipses
unquote
her tweet includes the title with the
words quote i spoke up against sexual
violence unquote prominently featured
nowhere in this tweet
or anywhere else does miss heard
disavow the title to the contrary
she's proclaiming it
and at the same time
ms heard posted this tweet she posted
another which you can see right beneath
it
quote
i'm honored to announce my role as an
aclu ambassador
on women's rights
unquote aggrandizing herself
at the expense of mr depp
so make no mistake
this was about mr depp
in the wake of the metoo movement
with her aclu ambassadorship and a major
movie coming out miss heard was trading
on her accusations of abuse against mr
deb
she was reminding everyone of those
allegations
she was once again taking on the role of
her lifetime the heroic survivor of
vicious abuse
or to use her phrase quote a public
figure representing abuse
and she was once again casting mr depp
as the villain in her drama the supposed
perpetrator of that abuse
when you meet to deliberate this case
you're going to be tasked with several
questions
those questions appear on a form that
you will use to reach your verdict in
this case
so i'd just like to ask you
please to spend a few minutes with me
going through that
tom would you please
put up the special verdict form so the
jury can see it
some of it's hard to read so maybe
tom might please blow it up
oh thank you very much
uh you will see here the first page of
the verdict form relating to mr depp's
claim for defamation against ms hurt
there are three pages relating to mr
depp's claim
one for each of the three defamatory
statements in the op-ed that form the
basis of mr depp's claim against ms hurd
you've heard those three statements many
times but they bear repeating i promise
just once more here
one
quote i spoke up against sexual violence
and faced our culture's wrath that has
to change unquote
two
then two years ago i became a public
figure representing domestic abuse and i
felt the full force of our culture's
wrath for women who speak out
unquote
three
i had the rare vantage point of seeing
in real time how institutions protect
men accused of abuse unquote
now there are seven questions that you
will need to please answer with respect
to each of those
statements so that's 21 questions i
think that seven as to each statement
one
was the statement made or published by
ms hurd
two
was the statement about mr depp
three was the statement false
four did the statement have a defamatory
implication about mr depp
five was the defamatory implication
designed and intended by miss heard
six
was the defamatory implication conveyed
to someone other than mr deb
seven
did miss heard make the statement with
actual malice which is your honor her
honor explained meaning did miss heard
make the statement knowing it was false
or with reckless disregard as as to the
truth
ladies and gentlemen the evidence
clearly shows that the answers
to those seven questions are all yes
and if you answer yes
to all of those questions which you
should we respectfully submit you will
be asked to state the amount of damages
to which mr depp is entitled
in the wake of the metoo movement movie
producers know better
than to cast a movie star
who has been accused of domestic and
sexual violence
and it is entirely within your
discretion as jurors to quantify the
amount of money that constitutes fair
compensation
for mr depp's pain and humiliation
inflicted by ms hurd's defamation
but while mr depp certainly is entitled
to monetary compensation
this case
at least for mr deb
has never been about money
this case for mr depp has never been
about money
nor is about is it about punishing this
hurt
it is about mr depp's reputation
and freeing him from the prison in which
he has lived for the last six years and
it's six years to the day
the most important questions for mr depp
the ones truly at the heart of this case
are questions two three and four on the
verdict form
and while tom's pulling that up let's
take question two
thank you thank you
were the statements about mr depp
yes
two points here one
when the aclu pitched the op-ed to the
washington post i think you'll remember
this
they pitched it as quote a piece by
amber heard
who as you know
was beaten up during her brief marriage
to johnny depp unquote
that's how they pitched it
two
after the op-ed was published
news outlets including usa today and
you've seen that that was an exhibit
characterized the op-ed as
referring to misheard's allegations
of abuse against mr deb
so the usa today interpreted that way
and so did many other publications they
got exactly the implication that ms
heard and the aclu
intended
them to have
tom if you would please pull up
plaintiff's exhibit
409
and 411 if you could put them
side by side
and this was expected this is what they
wanted
there had been a lot of press
two years prior to the publication of
the op-ed
about ms heard's claims of abuse against
mr depp when she walked into court with
her publicist
to obtain
the domestic violence the no notice
ex-parde meaning
mr depp's lawyer was not informed and he
was already in new york
which he testified ms hurd was well
aware of
you don't need a domestic violence
restraining order
when your husband is halfway across the
continent and is heading for a european
tour
on may 27 2016
with a purported mark in her face
everyone knew exactly
who who and what ms heard was referring
to in the op-ed she was referring to mr
deb
let's take questions two and three next
if we can
were each of the statements false
and did the statements have a defamatory
implication on mr deb again the clear
answer is yes
the statements understood in the context
of the op-ed itself
and in the broader context
of the press conf coverage of ms heard
walking into the court with a mark on
her face to obtain a domestic violence
restraining order against mr depp in may
2016
imply clearly imply that mr depp
physically and sexually abused ms hurd
the overwhelming
evidence
that
you all have heard and has come forward
in this case
shows that those allegations are false
and despicably false
mr depp did not physically abuse ms
heard
he did not sexually abuse ms heard
you've heard audio after audio where
miss heard admits that she was
physically abusing him
while mr depp's name will be forever
tarnished by these horrendous and false
allegations
this case is about telling you his story
and the truth about what really happened
which you've now heard
it is about
restoring his lost reputation
it's about showing mr depp's children
lily rose and jack
that the truth is worth fighting for
it is
and it's about restoring mr depp's name
and standing in the community to the
fullest extent that you can and you can
do something
and only you ladies and gentlemen can do
that for him
you heard from mr depp yesterday that he
has been carrying these outlandish
outrageous stories on his back
pretty stoically
and living them with them for six years
and waiting to be able to bring his
truth out and he has told you the truth
the unvarnished truth even truth did
pretty embarrassing he knew that was
going to happen when he brought this
case
you've seen the evidence in this case
over six long weeks which we again thank
you for
that evidence shows overwhelmingly that
miss herd's attempt to paint herself as
a heroic survivor
an innocent survivor
and mr depp as a terrifying abuser are
utterly
false
we ask you to please return your verdict
for mr deb we ask you we implore you to
give him his name
his reputation and his career back thank
you very much ladies and gentlemen all
right ladies and gentlemen let's go
ahead and take a break at this time
again this case has not been submitted
to you yet we will continue with closing
arguments we come back so do not discuss
the case with yourselves don't do any
outside research okay thank you
all right let's come back at 1105. oh
okay
okay sure
are we ready for the jury
okay
all right thank you may be seated all
right closing arguments mr rottenbord
okay thank you
this
good morning everyone
mr redmore's your mic on i just believe
it is oh there we go okay does that work
okay
in trying to convince you that mr death
has carried his burden of proof
in proving
that he was never abusive to amber on
even one occasion
think about the message that mr death
and his attorneys are sending to amber
and by extension to every victim of
domestic abuse everywhere
if you didn't take pictures
it didn't happen
if you did take pictures
they're fake
if you didn't tell your friends
you're lying
and if you did tell your friends
they're part of the hoax
if you didn't seek medical treatment you
weren't injured
if you did seek medical treatment
you're crazy
if you do everything that you can
to help your spouse the person that you
love
rid himself of the crushing drug and
alcohol abuse that spins him into an
abusive rage-filled monster you're a nag
and if you finally decide that enough is
enough
you've had enough of the fear
enough of the pain and you have to leave
to save yourself
you're a gold digger
that is the message that mr death is
asking you to say
but he doesn't stop there
because in mr depp's world you don't
leave mr death
and if you do
he will start a campaign of global
humiliation against you
a smear campaign
that lasts to this very day
he will do everything he can
to destroy your life
to destroy your career
that is what they're saying ladies and
gentlemen
and that's what they're trying to get
you the jury to be an accomplice to
but it's not surprising
because mr death
cannot and will not take responsibility
for his own actions
it's always someone else's fault
just as miss vasquez did
mr chu did i would like to extend my
thanks to you on behalf of amber and our
whole legal team
for the care and the diligence with
which you have served as jurors in this
matter
you've paid attention to every witness
every piece of evidence and i can't even
imagine the sacrifice that you've made
in terms of time away from your friends
your family
your job to be here on this jury it's a
very important role that you're serving
and we thank you very much
let's pick up where we started six weeks
ago in opening statement you may
remember that i asked you to keep a
simple question in mind which is
why are you here
and much of what you've heard during the
course of this trial
you don't need to make a decision on in
order to return a verdict or misheard on
mr depp's claim of defamation
now we'll talk about miss herb's claim
of defamation against mr deb and
elaine will address most of that in a
few minutes
but your key question to answer is does
the first amendment give miss heard the
right to write the words that she wrote
in this article
on december 18 2018 that's the question
and you cannot simultaneously protect
and uphold the first amendment and find
in favor of johnny depp on his claim you
simply cannot
you have to decide should someone be
able to write an article like that in
the united states of america without
being sued successfully without having
to go through the hell that ms hurt has
gone through
so let's talk about that and to do that
we get to explain a bit more about the
law that you have to follow
this is the op-ed piece i'm not going to
read it to you again you heard me read
it to you in opening statements and i
would urge you when you're in the
deliberation room read it
read it again and i know we focus on it
you know here and there over the course
of the trial but the vast majority of
this trial has not focused on these
words on this piece
this is obviously the paper edition
there's the online edition as well
now we get a chance to discuss with you
exactly what you have to find about this
article
let's try this again
this is one of the jury instructions
that you'll you'll get and i've been so
looking forward to being able to
actually explain to you as as the judge
read all the instructions to you this
morning and i know it's a lot but we've
been looking forward to being able to
explain to you what you're here to
decide because i imagine for some of the
case it's been kind of unclear what are
you being asked to decide
these are the things that you have to
find and you have to answer yes as mr
chu said you have to answer yes to all
of them in order to find in favor of mr
death
so you have to find that the statement
was about mr depp and you can decide
that in the context of the article and
i'll get to the arguments that mr depp
raises on that in a minute
you also have to find that the statement
is false
and we're going to look at the
statements here we're going to look at
each of the three statements and in
order to win his claim mr depp has to
prove every single element and and
there's a concept in the jury
instructions that you really didn't hear
from mr depp's this morning but you've
all heard it i'm sure outside the
courtroom which is burden of proof
it is mr depp's burden
to prove
each and every one of these elements
if he cannot misheard
wins
if he cannot prove each and every one of
these elements
under the burden of proof that's
applicable misheard wins there's two
different burdens of proof that we'll
get to
for all of them except number seven the
burden of proof is greater weight of the
evidence
so you weigh the evidence and you decide
has mr deb proven to you
the first six elements
the seventh one for actual malice the
clear and convincing evidence standard
we'll get to in a few minutes
but these are this is what he has to
prove
and he cannot do that
these are the three statements
and i know you may be thinking to
yourself wait a second don't we have to
decide
if mr deb committed abuse
and the answer is no you don't have to
because these three statements you can
decide as a matter of law or as a matter
of fact as you weigh the evidence and
the fact that they're true
so the first two statements i'm going to
address together then two years ago i
became a public figure representing
domestic abuse and i felt the full force
of our culture's wrath for women who
speak out
number two i had the rare vantage point
of seeing in real time how institutions
protect men accused of abuse
when you go back to the jury room to
deliberate you should feel free like i
said to read the article and think of
the article's purpose the jury
instructions also tell you to take these
statements in the context of the article
think about the purpose the purpose of
the article was to promote legislative
measures designed to protect victims of
domestic abuse designed to protect
people who did exactly what miss heard
did to speak out
that's apparent on the face of the
article and to do that miss heard talked
about her own life experiences as
someone who had obtained tro against mr
depp someone who would accuse mr depp of
domestic violence
make no mistake and and they mr depp
side keeps trying to say that we're
somehow suggesting that two years before
she wrote this that miss heard hadn't
had anything to do with mr depp we're
not saying that you heard it misheard
herself say of course two years before i
wrote this article
i felt the full force force of our
culture's wrath for women who speak out
after she obtained a temporary
restraining order against mr death
after she became a public figure
representing domestic abuse but the
words that she wrote here and then
chronicling her own experience after
that those words are true
those words are true
similarly the rare vantage point of
seeing based on her own experiences post
may 27 2016 how institutions protect men
accused of abuse those words are true
and the first amendment protects miss
herd's right to say them
now the third statement is absolutely
true as well but we're going to take
that separately because she didn't write
it
under the first amendment the statements
have to be false in order for mr debt to
win
now plaintiff address is like i said an
argument that we're not making and as i
said we're not running from the fact
that when she discussed becoming a
public figure representing domestic
abuse amber was speaking of her
experiences reporting domestic abuse
against johnny depp
she admitted to that but that doesn't
make the article or the statements about
johnny depp think about it think about
every piece of evidence that you've
heard over the last six weeks about his
abuse about their relationship
none of that is in the article
none of it
we all know that it would be a very
different article if she had written
about what she suffered that she's told
you about over the last six weeks
because he knows the words are true mr
depp says that the words now have a
defamatory implication he says the
statements are the same as saying
johnny depp abused me
but just because he wants to make the
article about himself doesn't mean it is
he has to show you
that any defamatory implication was
designed and intended
look at number four designed and
intended by ms heard to convey the
defamatory meaning that he suggests just
because people might read the article
and remember oh yeah amber heard used to
be married to johnny depp
and she accused him of abuse that
doesn't mean that she designed and
intended defamatory implications in
writing about herself and think about it
if mr depp is right then virtually any
statement that anyone could ever make
about their own life that implies
anything implies any involvement with
any other person could be defamatory and
that's clearly not what the first
amendment
intends
she didn't design and intend the words
to be the equivalent of writing johnny
depp abuse me and you don't have to take
her words for it you can take the words
of terence doherty of the aclu he said
that the op-ed wasn't even miss heard's
idea
the aclu wrote the first draft and great
care was taking taken in drafting the
article so as not to make it about mr
death or miss heard's relationship with
him
that's the only evidence presented about
miss heard's motive except her admit her
statements that that was exactly what
she wanted to do she wanted to talk
about her experiences after johnny depp
she wanted to own her story after johnny
depp and fit those into what other women
experience what other people experience
having accused someone of domestic abuse
and the backlash that they suffer and
then talk about legislative measure
measures that could help protect people
in those positions that's what she meant
and that's what the article is about
there's no hidden meaning here ladies
and gentlemen this isn't a hit piece on
johnny depp
this isn't a hit piece on johnny depp
and you can end here
you can end there
by saying the statements that she wrote
were not false and the first amendment
protects them
let's talk about the headline
for a minute the headline that was
published in the online version only of
the article on december 18 2018 said i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath
a few points here number one and this
evidence is undisputed there's no
dispute about this so as you weigh the
evidence
you you you don't have to check your
common sense at the door and you can
weigh circumstantial evidence you can
weigh facts but you can't see evidence
where no evidence exists and the
undisputed evidence here is that mrs
heard didn't write the headline
she didn't approve the headline
she had nothing to do with it
she was not given notice of the headline
she testified you saw her testify about
the sexual assault that she experienced
at the hands of mr death you saw her
testify about that that they're calling
her a liar
you saw her on the stand testify with
your own mouth
with her own mouth
exactly
exactly what she went through
for the first time in court because
people
who have suffered that they don't want
to broadcast that to the world
they want to penalize miss hurd for not
speaking about that earlier that's
ridiculous and it's insulting and it's
just victim blaming at its most
disgusting
the only reference to sexual assault in
the article
and you can read the op-ed is sexual
assault that she said she had
experienced by the time she was of
college age before mr depp so there is a
reference to sexual violence in that
article but it's not by mr deb
mr depp can't hold her liable for
headlines she didn't write it contained
something that had nothing that was not
about him and they want you to think
that she republished the headline
republish the headline by tweeting out
the link to the online version so let's
look at this
this is the tweet that she sent on
december 19th
the hyperlink
says opinion amber heard i spoke up
against sexual violence that's the
online version of the article as ms hurt
said you can't attach you can't tweet a
piece of paper
so when she wanted to share that she had
written this article what choice does
she have
she has to attach that link
and the jury instructions that you have
make clear that
a hyperlink
is not republication
forwarding a link on does not mean that
you broadcast the statement again but
that's what they want to make you think
the only way
and the jury instructions that you have
and we won't we don't need to read
through them in detail now but the
republication instruction says that
merely linking to an article does not
amount to republication but adding
content to a linked article may
constitute republication you must
determine whether any added content was
intended to reach a new audience and if
you find any content added to the
hyperlink was intended to reach a new
audience it constitutes a republication
there was no content added to the
article
she tweeted above the article simply
saying today i published this
that's what she said she didn't add any
content to it she could have added some
of the content that you've heard in this
courtroom to it she could have said not
only did two years ago i become a public
figure representing domestic abuse but
let me tell you about the domestic abuse
that i suffered that would be adding new
content
this is not adding new content but i
guess it's no surprise because this
whole case is about blaming amber heard
for things she didn't do but that's what
mr depp does
it's what he's always done blame other
people refuse to take accountability but
the problem for him here is that he's
running headlong into the united states
constitution which says that you cannot
hold amber her liable for words she
didn't write or publish
but here we are
here we are and you can decide this case
without ever wading into any
of the allegations
the facts the evidence that you've heard
about the heinous abuse the misheard
suffered at the hands of mr depp
you can decide that by determining that
those statements
are true
and they're protected by the first
amendment
but
mr depp brought this case and he's
suggesting that he was never abusive to
misheard
so that's where you want to make your
decision
that's where the road ends for mr
death ladies and gentlemen let me be
very clear
if amber was abused by mr deb even one
time
then she wins
one time
and we're not just talking about
physical abuse
we're talking about emotional abuse
psychological abuse
financial abuse
sexual abuse
that's what we're talking about
let's look at the evidence you heard mr
depp define abuse from his own mouth he
admitted all of that when he talked
about his childhood
as they referenced his mother called him
one eye because he had a lazy eye
and he said that that was worse than the
beatings that he took
worse than the beatings that he took
being called one eye by his mother was
worse than the beatings that he took
and after the evidence that you've seen
some of which you're going to see i want
you to think to
yourself is being called one eye
worse than what he did to misheard
absolutely not
you'll remember his expert shannon curry
agreed with all that that abuse can take
many forms
and you'll remember that don hughes miss
herd's expert talked about
the reports of intimate partner violence
by ms heard characterized by physical
violence psychological aggression sexual
violence coercive control and
surveillance behaviors she tested miss
heard she said that the tests show that
there's a high degree of serious
violence perpetrated by mr depp toward
misheard
she got that opinion and that impression
by reviewing the medical records of
misheard she talked about the role of
coercive control that mr depp exercised
over misheard the effect of coercive
control she said was drastic and it was
composed of things such as possessive
jealousy
the imbalance of power
not only in physical stature and
physical size
but in where they were in their life in
their career
by intimidation
she said writing obscene messages to
your partner can absolutely be
intimidating behavior
she said that mr depp after reviewing
the evidence banging and throwing and
hitting things in the household that's
psychological aggression
punching a wall throwing something
screaming that is abuse
that's abuse ladies and gentlemen
she said alcohol can just throw lighter
fluid off of flame in a situation of
domestic violence
all of these things constitute the
domestic violence that misheard suffered
at the hands of mr death and he's trying
to get you to fool you
to believing that he's carried his
burden of proof that never a single time
in their relationship was he in any way
physically or not physically abusive to
misheard and that's ridiculous that's
ridiculous so let's look at some of that
evidence and like i said you can apply
your own common sense you don't need to
check that at the door when you go into
the deliberation room i'm going to walk
you through the evidence some of the
evidence has been presented including
evidence from mr depp's own mouth his
own words or the words of his witnesses
keep in mind the burden of proof
and as we go through this evidence i'd
ask you to keep this in mind as well
it's not about who's the better spouse
it's not about whether you think miss
heard may have been abusive to mr depp
it's not because remember if you think
that they were both abusive to each
other and that's what their witness
laura anderson testified to then amber
wins
they're trying to trick you into
thinking that amber has to be perfect in
order to win
even while they're ignoring jade mr
depp's many flaws but don't fall for
that trick amber's not perfect none of
us are she's never pretended to be and
that's not what you're being asked to
decide
one time ladies and gentlemen one time
if he abused her one time amber wins
actually if he fails to prove that he
never abused her one time amber wins
so let's take a look at some of the
evidence this was one of the first
messages shown to mr depp
in his cross-examination
this is a message to paul bettany his
drug buddy early on in their
relationship
when he says let's burn amber
let's drown her before we burn her
i will [ __ ] her burnt corpse afterwards
to make sure she is dead
some of the most vile disgusting
language that you could ever imagine
that is what he said to her at the
beginning of the relationship
so let's look at how the relationship
was bookended
you remembered mr depp the other day in
response to some texts that we'll see
later saying i don't write like that
this is a book end of the relationship
this is after it was over
i asked mr depp to read that top text
you'll remember that was the only thing
i asked him to read and he immediately
said i didn't write that text even
though
of course he did
even though he wrote the text under word
under it that said hopefully that cunt's
rotting corpse is decomposing in the
[ __ ] trunk of a honda civic that's
how he bookended their relationship
ladies and gentlemen these words
are a window into the heart and mind of
america's favorite pirate
this is the real johnny depp
this is the real johnny depp after miss
heard decided that she
couldn't take it anymore decided that
she needed to leave him and i'm not
going to reread this whole text to you
but this is where she says she's begging
for global humiliation
and she's going to get it
he says i'll stop at nothing and i can
only hope that karma kicks in and takes
the gift of breath from her
it's one of the only promises to mr miss
her that mr depp has ever kept
that's how he ended the relationship but
you saw how he started it
now
misheard did testify on the stand that
mr depp abused her countless times first
it started they were very happy they
started dating in 2011
and things were good and she testified
that even during periods of abuse even
during their relationship when there was
abuse occurring that there were periods
where they were very happy it's the
cycle of violence
it's the cycle of sobriety
there were periods when everything was
good
when the monster was gone and then the
monster would return
you heard about how the first incident
of violent incidents of violence took
place in 2012 when ms hurd asked johnny
about his
tattoo that used to say winona forever
and had been changed to say why no
forever and she laughed
and she said and he slapped me across
the face she thought it was a joke and
then he did it two more times and then
he said
i thought i put the monster away and
i've done it before
that's what she
he said to her during that first
incidence of violence
but you don't just have to take
what mr depp said
in his text we can hear through his own
voice
what he called his heard
[Music]
we talked about the monster you heard mr
depp get on the stand and say that that
was miss heard's term
she made it up
that was what
she used
to refer to him when she was nagging him
she didn't want him to have a good time
she didn't want him to have a beer once
in a while that's what he's implying
but no this was a term created by mr
death that she heard for the first time
in 2012 after he slapped her three times
across the face and said i thought i put
the monster away
and after he sat up here on the stand
under oath and told you that she made
that term up
we look back at his texts the writing at
the time
the first text is after australia in
2015 during a period of sobriety a
short-lived period of recovery from mr
depp when he told jerry judge his
bodyguard all i had to do was send the
monster away and lock him up
remember he texted elton john or sent an
email to elton john in 2012 referring to
himself as the monster
he tells dr kipper the doctor to whom
he's paid millions and millions and
millions of dollars thank you my darling
kipper
he says i've locked my monster child
away in a cage deep within
he tells stephen deuters
you know mr deuters he liked to text mr
duders
he tells him she thinks my peruvian
peruvian period which is a reference to
cocaine he admitted to that
that that means him using cocaine has
made me a monster and that i am ruining
the relationship
imagine that someone actually thinking
that maybe the impact of alcohol and
cocaine is ruining a relationship how
dare she
he says need to discuss the news
helicopters the monster i want to shoot
a [ __ ] but don't worry the
monster is not not involved mr depp
knows that he can turn into a monster he
knows that
he knows that he got up here on the
stand and tried to deny that to you talk
about lack of accountability
let's see the monster
let's see the monster in the flesh
[Music]
ah
[ __ ]
what happened
[Music]
what happened
[Music]
[Music]
nothing happened this morning you know
that
[Music]
were you in here
no
nothing happened to you this morning
yeah you're right i just woke up and you
were so sweet and nice
[Music]
we were not even fighting this morning
all i did was say sorry did something
happen
to you
this morning
i don't think so
no that's the thing you want to see
craig don't give you a [ __ ] person
oh you're crazy
are you crazy have you drunk this whole
thing this morning oh you got this guy
you got this going
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
do you see miss her laughing in that
she's not laughing in that
mr depp in this courtroom right now is
laughing and making snide remarks as
that video is being played
but it's not a laughing matter
who does that
who does that
imagine being in amber shoes on february
10 2016 videotaping him when he's
because when he's sober and sweet you've
never loved anything more but when he
mixes the drugs and he mixes drinks he
turns into this man you've seen it
before
you're praying it won't happen again but
deep down you know it will
you know that that man will come out you
know that monster will come out and you
want him to change
imagine watching your husband the person
you love behaving violently that way
like a wild animal
that is abuse
that's abuse
and you don't have to look at that
incident in isolation to find that it's
abuse you can look at it in the context
of their whole relationship this isn't
about breaking down a series of
individual days that you've heard
evidence about this is about the the
cumulative effect of mr death and
misheard's relationship and whether that
constitutes abuse that is abuse ladies
and gentlemen that's domestic abuse
and their response is
she sold it to tmz which she didn't
there's no evidence of and she was on a
plane the only evidence suggests she was
on an international flight
when mr tremaine testified that they
received it and it was validated within
something like 15 minutes which could
only have happened by the person who
sent it
misheard was in the air she didn't send
it to tmz she never leaked anything to
tmz as you heard from her own mouth who
would want that to become public
again
in order to find for mr death you would
have to find that for his defamation
claim
every single thing that ever happened
between them that could constitute abuse
amber was the abuser every single time
you have to believe the unbelievable you
all are smarter than that
but mr death
thought he could hide it he thought he
could hide the monster that's why he
lied
in
insurance form so you have to fill out
in order to be able to act that's why he
said he hadn't taken illegal substances
whether prescribed by a physician or not
that obviously wasn't true in the past
12 months
they keep talking about mr depp's
roll as a father this is what he what he
sent
a text that he sent dx207 now lily rose
his daughter hates me because she thinks
i'm drinking and she's right but i can't
or a [ __ ] die in her eyes
thanks for that one vanessa
this is mr depp passed out in a tokyo
hotel room during the press tour for the
lone ranger in 2013 when miss heard
testified that mr depp screamed at me
and all i could think were the kids are
in an adjoining room and mr depp passed
out with his head
like this
i don't think he was sleeping on the
floor because he had a bad back they
keep referring to these pictures as she
took pictures of mr dev while he was
asleep
he's not asleep in that picture he's
passed out drunk and high and she's
taking pictures because she wants him to
realize what he's done and get help and
seek help
i don't think that looks like
the spice cabinet of anyone in this
courtroom
that's mr deb
this is mr deb
this is mr deb
this is mr deb
and all you hear from mr deb
when these pictures are shown is
snickering and defiance
victim blaming blaming misheard
for taking this picture of him for
trying to help
so let's talk about some of these
instances of abuse oh forgot one
in march 2013
talked about the wino forever tattoo in
march 2013 there were a couple instances
there was one where on march 8th and
we'll get to that in a second where he
was drinking brown liquor and doing a
lot of cocaine
but that might have been mark sorry that
was march 22nd on march 8th this is when
mr deb backhanded her she felt like her
lip went into her teeth and got a little
blood on the wall
he grabbed her by the arm and held her
on the floor screaming at her
we'll come back to this in a minute
this is march 22nd
this is what mr depp said isn't every
hour happy hour again totally abandoning
any responsibility for behavior like
this but what happened on march 22nd is
he wanted miss her to remove a painting
by her ex-partner and he wanted to admit
to an affair that she wasn't having
she didn't admit to it because it wasn't
true so he decided to have some lines of
cocaine and some whiskey for breakfast
and then on the way to filming the keith
richards documentary after a multi-hour
argument he grabbed
their dog their teacup yorkie
and holds the dog boo out of the window
of a moving car
and he's howling like an animal miss
heard said while holding the dog out of
the car that is abuse ladies and
gentlemen
that's abuse
let's go back to this because
miss vasquez read a parade of witnesses
that she believes support johnny's
defense in this case
but as you've seen over the course of
this proceeding
these witnesses
as i previewed in the opening almost all
of them are witnesses on his payroll
they're all scared to say anything bad
about him and they've seen what happens
to people who do and none were there for
the instances of domestic violence what
they're saying is oh if he didn't abuse
ms hurd in front of his four bodyguards
and it must have never happened that's
essentially what they're asking you to
believe
that's ridiculous that's not the way
domestic violence works take his sister
christy i know it seems like a year ago
but she was the first witness in this
case
you'll remember her on the stand when i
presented her with these texts to say
stop drinking stop coke and stop pills
you'll remember her squirming and saying
i don't think i was asking him to stop
drinking stop coke stop pills
she couldn't even answer that basic
question because she wanted to lie from
mr depp and say that
miss herd was delusional she couldn't
even admit this to you she's nothing but
an enabler the same with sean bett his
head of security who's been sitting in
this courtroom for the past six weeks
he's right there
mr bett was the one who testified to you
that when mr deaf has a few drinks of
alcohol he said
i wrote this down he said it's like the
rest of us drinking sparkling water
i don't think that kitchen video that we
just saw was like you or i when we drink
sparkling water
this is the same sean vette who said
that on the evening of may 21st 2016
which elaine will talk about a little
bit he said mr depp may have bumped
something off a table
you've seen the pictures you'll see them
again
just like travis mcgivern
said that mr depp rearranged miss
heard's closet you've seen the pictures
you'll see him again
just like tara roberts in the bahamas
who tried to blame everything on
misheard and only under cross
examination admitted that mr depp passed
out face down in the sand underneath a
hammock and his son jack found him there
she took a video of their cabin in the
bahamas
to try to suggest to you that this
assault that misheard alleges couldn't
have taken place but conveniently she
didn't take the camera into the closet
where mr depp
held miss heard hit her
we'll get to that incident she didn't
take the video camera into the bathroom
where he sexually assaulted miss her
she didn't do that
because she wanted to generate evidence
only favorable to mr death think about
sean bette and starling jenkins
conflicting stories about the birthday
party on april 21st remember mr depp
experienced horrific financial news the
evening of that night april 21st 2016.
he learned that he was essentially out
of money and he needed to start selling
things we all know what mr depp does
when he receives bad news like that
he left the meeting at 9 30 and didn't
arrive at miss heard's birthday party
until 11 15. okay fine he was late but
we all know what he does when he has
that hour and 45 minutes of free time
and he's stressed out about something mr
bett
testified
remember he said i took him to his home
on sweets or avenue his other home to
pick up a birthday present for miss
heard that's what he said
that's what he said mr jenkins you may
remember him he testified by the video
link on the stand and i said you don't
know what he did in that intervening
time period and he said oh yes i do i do
he said
mr depp was visiting his sick mother
and i said who told you that and he said
mr bett
the witnesses
that mr death has paraded up here who
are here in person they're here in
person because they're on his payroll
almost all of them
and they're telling you whatever they
think they need to tell you
to get you to take mr depp's
just as we previewed they would do in
the opening
but mr depp would go through periods
where he would apologize where he would
be grateful i have no doubt that there
were times when mr depp wanted to get
better
these are texts px
and 120b i won't read them all to you
these are texts that mr depp sent to
pageherd
amber's mom
after
detox on the island in 2014.
he says there were more than a few times
when i thought it would be more simple
to take that route
meaning go for a swim and swallow a big
drink of ocean
he said it was amber and amber alone
that got me through this
there is no luckier man on this earth to
have the strength that amber gives me
and the full support of each of you so
as you're weighing the evidence and
you're weighing mr depp's credibility
think to yourself what do i believe what
he has a motive to say on the stand or
what he wrote contemporaneously with the
events
take his own words to amber after the
detox just to let you know that i'm fine
my angel i miss you of course but this
was the right thing to do to speed up
the process i love you more than life
but then there were these days then
there were times like this
this is sent on march 9th we had a
slightly grim morning is the way mr depp
describes it
you'll remember the text from a few days
later
referred to as the disco bloodbath text
where miss heard says is that about last
friday night by any chance that mr depp
responds how can you make me smile about
such a hideous moment he testified on
the stand i don't remember what happened
that friday night but miss heard sure
did
and this
this is what one of the things that she
had to show for now miss vasquez showed
this to you in opening statements and
made it seem like again remember what i
said at the beginning if you take
pictures
they're fake if you didn't take pictures
it didn't happen here's one where she
did take a picture but miss vasquez says
but she doesn't have injuries on her
face look at the date that this picture
was taken ladies and gentlemen march
23rd
2013 15 days after this incident
so even when there are pictures
they're trying to deceive you into
thinking oh there should have been more
this is a two week old bruise
and she texts it look who she texts that
to she texted to her mom
they say
she never told anyone
text to mom march 23 2013.
let's go to hicksville you remember
hicksville obviously
there's been a little bit of discussion
about that in this case this is where mr
depp got jealous that a woman named
kelly sue was sitting close to miss herd
and maybe had her arm around her at a
campfire and everyone was having a good
time there were some mushrooms involved
there was some drinking
and mr depp got jealous of that now he
claims that miss hurt is the abuser that
she's so much stronger than he is but
then he testified that the evidence
shows that in hicksville he was the one
who said he was just trying to protect
amber
well who says why would she need
protection if she's the abuser and he
went and he took kelly sue's hand
forcibly removed it from misheard
embarrassing misheard ruining the mood
the whole night so they went they got
into an argument in the trailer in which
not only did he trash the trailer but he
took her into the bathroom he slammed
her up against the side wall of the
bedroom by her neck holds her there
and no sorry that he that was that was
the next one in hicksville he
took her into the bathroom of the
trailer and did what he called a cavity
search where he inserted his fingers
inside of her and sexually assaulted her
then trashed the trailer
and you heard
this
morgan night person who testified a few
days ago who said it was 62 dollars of
damage
you also heard evidence that the way he
got involved in this trial was by
reaching out to
a
one of the main johnny depp fan fan
influencers on social media and you saw
that text that's how he injected himself
into this trial
there was way more than 62 dollars of
damage you heard testimony from rocky
pennington
whitney heard
whitney enriquez and amber about him
trashing the trailer and is that really
a surprise the man's admitted that he
smashes things when he gets angry the
man's admitted that he smashed hotel
rooms you saw the quote that he admitted
to the other day that when he wants to
hit something he's going to hit it and
he doesn't care about the repercussions
so in hicksville
this is the hicksville was late may
2013. this is a text another text the
drug buddy bedne where he says
i of course pounded and displayed ugly
colors to amber on recent journey i am
an insane person and not so fair-headed
after too much of the drink
weed pills fine
booze
my capacity is too large and i won't
stop
ugly and sad oh how i love it
there appears to be an amber alert but i
think we're okay
people are getting it i guess on their
phones that haven't silenced that okay
okay
can i keep going
thank you
yes sir
[Music]
so that's
that's after hicksville this this is
what i was getting to next this remember
uh the testimony about mr depp being
drunk on his yacht
on the island in the bahamas in 2013
when mr death looked a little scary by
the way his body fell into the water
and lily rose his daughter started to
cry
miss heard comforted lily rose and then
depp accused amber of making them aware
of this that he was drinking again
making his kids aware of this and he
slammed her up against the side wall of
the bedroom held her up by her neck held
her there for a second and said i can
[ __ ] kill you and you're an
embarrassment
that's what he said and then do you
remember what
happened lily rose and amber
helicoptered away from the island
and while
amber was in the helicopter with lily
rose mr depp sends her this piece of
poetry
calling her a lesbian camp counselor
because she cared about his drinking and
just ridiculing her
for trying to protect
his daughter
sickening
this text
let's fast forward a little bit
to
actually before we talk about this this
is the boston flight let's talk about
the moscow flight the moscow flight when
mr death and amber she said that was the
one time she took ecstasy or mdma with
mr depp and she learned her lesson when
he hit her on the plane when he
threatened to break the flight
attendant's wrist and miss
vasquez again
just tried to tell you oh he always wore
rings now miss heard said almost all the
time he did maybe sometimes when he
didn't and in the picture that she just
showed you px1248 you can take a look at
that when you review the evidence that's
a picture taken in moscow
with no rings other than a wedding ring
on his finger or some kind of ring he's
wearing one ring on his finger
and so
in mr depp's world they're going to try
to come at you either way
they say well he was wearing rings but
it didn't leave a mark on your face and
then they show you a picture where he
wasn't wearing rings during that trip
so that's what happened in moscow on
september 2013 in london mr depp was
filming with paul bettany he missed a
few days of work going on a multi-day
drug binge
and that's when he told mr miss heard
that if she accepted an invitation and
went to a concert with a friend that she
was starring in a movie with that the
engagement would be off talk about
coercive control that don hughes
testified is abuse that is abuse
and there's been a lot
mentioned in this case by mr depp about
misheard not wanting him to leave
miss her not wanting him to leave well
this is why she didn't want him to leave
because he goes off with his friends and
he twists off as he calls it and goes on
a multi-day bender that's why she didn't
want him to leave when he got spun up
like that and she could see the monster
coming so let's fast forward to the
boston plane incident
mr depp was jealous that she was filming
a movie with james franco and this heard
testified that when she met him in
boston she was on the plane his car
pulled up she could guess by the way he
was moving she knew what was going to
board that plane and it wasn't mr depp
the man it was mr depp the monster she
said i already know he's drunk i already
know he's using and then when he got on
the plane he straight up started
taunting her he called her a go-getter
and a [ __ ]
he started throwing things at her ice
cubes and utensils and he slapped her
face
against the window
when she was seated and when she got up
to move how dare she he kicked her in
the back she said i feel this boot in my
back and he continued to drink and
eventually started howling like an
animal passed out in the bathroom
let's play 221 please
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that's mr depp on the plane but he
expects you to believe him that he
didn't have anything to drink on that
plane except for maybe one thing of
champagne that's what he expects you to
believe
he's talked about blackouts
these blackouts where he doesn't
remember what happened he blamed them
only on opiates but we know they happen
throughout where he doesn't remember
what's happened is you're weighing the
evidence as you're assessing whether mr
depp has borne his burden of proof think
to yourself do you believe
amber's account of what happened on the
plane or do you believe
that person's account that you just
heard
but actually you can look at his account
from a few days later
may 30th in which he told again paul
bettany he said drank all night before i
picked amber up to fly to la
no food for days powders half a bottle
of whiskey a thousand red bulls and
vodkas pills two bottles of champagne
and what do you get an angry aggro
engine and a [ __ ] blackout screaming
obscenities and insulting any [ __ ] who
got near i'm done i'm admittedly too
[ __ ] in the head to spray my rage at
the one i love
for little reason as well i'm too old to
be that guy but pills are fine
and he expects you to believe that he's
carried his burden of proof in showing
that no abuse happened on that plane
you don't have to look at just that
you can look at this text of patty smith
when he says
when i was in nyc they were brief visits
and i [ __ ] and charged by horrific
fights with amber i [ __ ] up and drank
and got shitty was so disappointed in
myself
you can look at his text to misheard the
next day where he says once again
i find myself in a place of shame and
regret
of course i'm sorry i really don't know
why or what happened well no wonder you
heard the voice on the plane of course
he doesn't know what happened but i will
never do it again my illness somehow
crept up and grabbed me i must get
better
i love you and feel so bad for letting
you down and what his response has been
throughout this trial things like that
is blaming amber saying he's just
placating her
is that carrying his burden of proof and
showing that abuse hasn't happened even
a single time
this is in the lead up to australia but
before we get there we can talk about
january 25th in tokyo at the premiere of
mordecai where he did
slam her up against the hallway wall
wailed on her and he did get on her back
in the closet and what do they say look
at her backless dress she doesn't have
any bruises she testified herself that
she was checking out pictures because
she was concerned that there were so now
their theory is if there's no marks it
didn't happen
we all know that's not the case
february 2015 this is when they got
married the day they got married you
heard the testimony from io till it
write that where mr depp told him i can
now punch her anytime i want and no one
can do anything about it
he'll say it's a joke a joke he made on
his wedding day then we fast forward to
australia where miss hurt is flying from
london where she's filming the danish
girl to see her new husband for the
first time since their wedding and these
are excerpts from dx353
all but the bottom right one are in the
days leading up to this where he's on a
drug fueled bender he's hanging out with
marilyn manson he's getting drugs from
his assistants who are enablers again
there's a reason you didn't hear them
testify in this trial
they're getting him drugs for days and
days and then the one on the bottom
right you'll remember you've seen a
couple times this is after he chopped
his finger off when he says need more
cocaine and ecstasy
so and no one misheard was in touch with
his assistants but no one told her the
hornet's nest that she was walking into
and we all know what happened in
australia
we all know that
mr depp she gets there he pulls out a
bag of mdma and he took a handful she
didn't say he took 10 at a time she did
say he took 8 to 10 over the course of
that period
the second day mr depp who claims that
miss heard
refused to do a post nup calls amber's
domestic relations attorney michelle
mulrooney you heard from her when he was
drunk and he fired her and he told amber
for about the 25th time she said the
only way out of this is death i don't
want to post nothing.
and then she said she remembered him
slamming up against the wall and i won't
go through you remember her testimony
from australia you remember her saying
that he had her by the neck squeezing
her neck you remember her saying that he
threw her on the game's table like a
ping pong table you remember seeing the
pictures of that broken table
you remember her saying that at some
point he had a broken bottle up against
her face and he told her that he'd carve
up her face that he was throwing bottles
at her
he's throwing bottles one after another
and i could feel glass breaking behind
me and you've seen the evidence of that
and he was just over and over again
smashing the phone into the wall
screaming at me as she watched it break
into pieces
now she doesn't know how he lost his
finger
she said that she saw him smash a phone
to pieces and you heard him get
impeached the other day with his
testimony from the uk which was
different from what he testified here
where he said he did smash a phone and
then they tried to put that picture in
front of you with a desk phone and
suggest that that was it
it's deception
they're trying to deceive you
and then you heard miss her testify that
the next morning
she found meat that he had left all over
the house
but not before
what happened
before she went to bed that night
we're miss her testified and i remember
trying to get up and i was slipping on
the glass
i was wanting to move
i felt this pressure pressure in my
pubic bone
i remember just not wanting to move
because i didn't know if it was broken
i didn't know if the bottle that he had
inside me
was broken
this is the next morning
this is what he wrote with a bloody
stump of his finger and there's been
testimony about what happened to cut the
finger off but frankly it's irrelevant
to your deliberations here amber could
have chopped it off with an axe and it
has nothing to do with whether or not mr
depp abused her but we all know she
didn't we all know that his fingers
weren't curled and someone was standing
with a half gallon vodka bottle from
about where that canopy is and threw it
and it somehow managed to damage just
the bottom of the finger
and leave the nail fully intact we all
know that didn't happen
mr depp knows it didn't happen we'll see
some evidence of that but here
he writes about her ambition starring
billy bob and easy amber we talked about
controlling jealousy talked about him
not wanting her to act don hughes
testified how that is a form of intimate
partner abuse
he or she right he's writing on the
mirror again and they try to blame her
and say that she wrote call carly simon
she didn't write that
who was the lunatic in the house
who was writing everywhere
she there's no evidence she wrote that
she testified she doesn't know who carly
simon was until she was told
this is some of the evidence mr depp
told you a couple different stories the
other day about the the evidence on the
right he claimed that that was the
handle of vodka between those two
beer cans there
but then under cross examination he
admitted it's not that there's not
enough glass in the floor that there's
no handle of vodka on the floor but what
there is in the picture on the right is
evidence of when he was throwing bottles
past amber's head and breaking that
plate glass window more writing more
abuse on the right imagine having a
painting
area where you're drawing two canvases
and you and your husband get in a fight
and while you are asleep that night he
takes the bloody stump of his finger and
dips it in paint and destroys your
paintings ladies and gentlemen that's
abuse
good luck and be careful at the top and
this is a good chance to talk about mr
jeff's mr depp's controlling
and jealous rage and his desire to
control amber's career
he didn't want her to act as early as
2013 he tells his sister i don't need
actress [ __ ] and her [ __ ]
ambition
he tells her in this recording
when you're doing movies i become
jealous and [ __ ] crazy and weird and
you know we fight
a lot more
become jealous when you're doing movies
i become irrational and [ __ ] crazy
and weird
out of his own mouth
this is some of the notes of dr
blaustein
his therapist called himself destructive
something about wait up to fight the
devil
jealous
and i know this is hard to read but you
can see jealous you see paranoia fear
envy
he wanted to control her he wanted to
own her he didn't want her to have any
career
and then he says things like i have
other uses for your throat which do not
include injury
no one who
hasn't previously grabbed someone by the
throat would write which do not include
injury but we all know how mr death
thinks along these lines because you saw
these two texts the other day that he
sat on the stand and denied writing and
i'm not going to read them to you again
because they're the most vulgar vile
writing you can imagine he said that's
not my style i wouldn't write like that
of course he would and he did these are
texts that he produced that he gave to
amber and our team in this litigation
from him to his personal assistant
stephen deuters this is the way he
thinks about women
this not what you heard on the stand
that
it's disgusting
he admitted that he cut his finger off
these this is evidence of him admitting
to it to people other than amber i cut
the top of my middle finger off says
that to dr kipper
says it again to dr kipper the bottom
one he said says to nurse pilate i just
chopped my finger off but he does say it
to amber too remember we played this one
four times and mr depp denied that he
was actually saying the day that i
chopped my finger off let's hear it one
more time
i'm talking about australia today though
we're talking about australia okay
the day that i chopped my finger off
so let's fast forward to march 23rd
2015.
after just a few weeks in australia mr
depp has a finger injury no doubt about
that he comes home
he gets what they call a soft cast on it
which you heard his treating physician
and our experts say doesn't have sides
on it but it's a hard plaster cast over
the top of his finger that can be
wielded like a club
and they got an argument when miss heard
discovered that he was having an affair
with a woman named rochelle that had
been going on before the wedding after
the wedding
and she confronted him about that
no surprise there they got in the huge
argument
at some point in the argument he bolted
up the stairs now travis mcgiverns
claims that she threw a red bull can at
him
she and whitney enriquez say that
absolutely didn't happen but even if you
believe mr mcgivern
at some point
mr depp
went up the stairs he went to the fight
this is the man that claims he always
wants to run and this time he had his
bodyguard with him so he could have just
walked out the door but he runs up the
stairs and miss enriquez is standing on
the precipice of the stairs and amber
admitted
that when she thought he was about to
push her down the stairs as he's
grabbing at her and amber with his free
hand and trying to club them with the
casted hand
that she said i punched him square in
the face
i punched some square in the face and
they showed you a picture of the shiner
that she had
that that mr depp had miss hurt doesn't
deny that
they're trying to say she's the abuser
for defending herself and her sister
from this animal who's running at them
this person that they claim couldn't
possibly have done this because he had
a hurt finger
yet he could have done this this is what
mr mcgivern said was rearranging her
closet
i don't know what you all do when you
rearrange your closets but i hope it
doesn't look like this this is throwing
clothing rack down the stairs this is
knocking this over this is what he did
to rearrange her closet
with his hurt finger that he couldn't
possibly have hit misheard with they
claimed
that in and of itself that destruction
of property even if he hadn't hit her
that night that's abuse imagine being
married to someone and walking on
eggshells so thick that you don't know
if you set them off if that's what's
going to happen
that's abuse
and it's disgusting
but sometimes he would apologize he'd
say i can't express how sorry i am for
having stooped so low as to have spewed
such vicious untruths for the sole
purpose of hurting you grievous error
shameful so he went in these cycles
he went in these cycles she thought he
could change for good and when it was
good it was really good but then
sometimes things like december 15th came
around where she remembers him chasing
her in the kitchen
she remembers him shoving her two or
three times and sending her toppling
over a chase lounge and saying you
really want to go again tough guy and
she looked at him and he balled up his
fist leaned back and headbutted her
square in the nose
and pounded her head with the back of
his fist so she couldn't breathe on that
bed that we're gonna see in a second
where she was suffocating in this pillow
top and she said this is when i thought
i was gonna die he's gonna kill me and
he doesn't even know what he's doing
because he's out of his mind and
these are the pictures that they claim i
don't know what they're claiming i don't
know if they're claiming
she painted on the bruise
oh you weren't hurt badly enough so
therefore you're making it up look under
her
eye
and again their theory is that all of
this is a lie all of this was some grand
hoax
if this were a hoax ladies and gentlemen
she'd have
worse injuries than that she'd really do
it up she took pictures as they existed
when she could at the time of abuse and
yet miss vasquez has the nerve to say
well why didn't she videotape an
incident of abuse what if she's being
hit she's supposed to somehow grab a
video camera with one hand while she's
defending herself with another hand you
heard her in one of the audio tapes
talking about when she hit him as he was
trying to barge at her and she got her
feet caught under a door
as he's coming after her
and of course as don hughes testify to
victims of course of control like this
they do try to
appease their abusive partner and
apologize for things that aren't their
fault so as you're coming at me johnny
and you push a door into me and i have
to hit you to get away to protect myself
yeah she did apologize for that because
that's the cycle of violence that's what
victims do yet they continue to blame
the victim
there's no evidence she painted on that
bloody lip and again we're talking about
a hoax the next day she went on james
gordon and they say well you can't see
any injury there so it must not have
happened
she would have to be
the dumbest person in the world to say
i'm going to commit an abuse hoax but
let's let's do it the day before i go on
national television
let's do it the day before
but you heard melanie iglesias her
makeup artist testify in great detail
and i didn't even understand half the
terms about makeup that she was using
but she testified in great detail about
exactly what she did to cover up those
bruises
the red lipstick that she put to cover
up the busted lip
you heard the testimony of that
from a neutral party
who said exactly what she did she talked
about how she looked at the color wheel
to neutralize the bruising
they claim it was just an accidental
headbutt well no accidental headbutt
rips out hair
they claim oh this hurts somehow used a
pocket knife to cut this portion of the
bed out to stage this well i don't know
if that's a pocket knife or not but the
only testimony in this trial about a
pocket knife is whitney henriquez saying
that mr depp carried a pocket knife in
his pocket every day
we all know where that if it is a pocket
knife where that came from
i think the most telling one of the most
telling things about this incident is
the text he sent to david heard amber's
dad two weeks later where he says i
meant to send this to you a week or so
ago
i'm sending it to you now and he says
i forget if it's a text or an email but
you can look at dx580 he says yes i
[ __ ] up and went too far in our fight
because as a result of that fight and
the bruises that all of her family saw
the family refused to go to the bahamas
with them for christmas
the family refused to go to the bahamas
for christmas and on that trip
to the island
mr depp kept passing out and every time
he passed out he would dump a glass of
wine on amber's lap and she didn't like
that and she yelled at it
and because it was in front of his kids
he got up this is the one where tara
roberts took the video but she didn't
show you the closet she didn't show you
the bathroom and amber says while
holding my neck this is in the closet he
said i'll [ __ ] kill you if you ever
speak to me like that in front of my
kids again because you embarrass me and
then he took her into the bathroom and
she said but this time he grabbed my
vagina
shoved his fingers inside me but threw
my bathing suit and held me there and
asked me if i was so [ __ ] tough
and then she ran out
of the house and to keep him away from
her
that's when he claims and she admits she
threw something at him she didn't know
what it was there's it's been tested
when he was a can of mineral experience
that she claimed that that hit mr death
and mr depp is somehow the victim in
that encounter
come on
we talk about the plane the train ride
to asia we you saw the pictures taken
before they got on the train ride where
mr depp has the same
shadowing under his eye that he does in
the allegedly abusive picture but in
that picture he held miss her in that
train ride
talk about a honeymoon he held her up
against the wall while she was trying to
get his arms off her neck and he was
squeezing her neck against the railroad
car and at some point i pull the lapel
of the shirt he rips the shirt off and
she woke up with the shirt around her
neck and a giant knot in the back of her
head
let's fast forward to
uh her birthday party just very quickly
he experienced terrible financial news
that night he came over they got into a
fight there's been conflicting evidence
about that but amber said i hit the side
of the desk he chest bumped me he fell
to the floor i fell to the floor and
when i got back up he held me down by
the shoulders and that's when he grabbed
her by the pubic bone and pushed her
down and you'll remember miss vasquez
showing her her interrogatory answers
where she details a lot of this and
saying nowhere in there does it say that
and misheard says it actually does on
page 64. and pointed out to ms vasquez
exactly where it says that that's abuse
it's sexual abuse
but we all know what mr depp does when
he experiences terrible financial news
or terrible news he experienced terrible
news that night on the way to the
birthday party where his both of his
bodyguards have testified that he was
either visiting his sick mom or getting
a birthday present for amber
and then we know what happens the day
after his mother passed away on may 21st
2016.
and
we're going to skip through a little bit
of this now
and elaine will talk about this in the
context of the counter claim but these
are the pictures afterwards these are
pictures that now they're claiming that
they must have been faint there's been
no testimony in this case these pictures
were faked there's been no testimony
that the marks you see on amber's face
including this mark with a straight line
from below her eye to the top of her
temple that
lines up directly with the phone there's
been no testimony that those are faked
mr depp went through the house he
destroyed pictures of her friends that's
abuse property destruction like that it
in and of itself is abuse he destroyed
her office he destroyed her friend rocky
pennington's
preparation for the bead show that she
was having
he spilled wine in the hallway that
you'll notice the police denied oh there
was no spilled wine in the hallway well
even isaac baroosh
testified that he saw this in the
hallway
and they said she never said anything to
her medical providers these are the
texts that she sent to her nurse erin
fellotti
the night that it happened
these are pictures of her in the
courtroom
we're not going to play this right now
but you can listen to this this is that
terribly disturbing text of him in july
of 2016
threatening to cut himself and telling
you cut me or i will
you all remember playing that it was
awful
it was awful i'm not gonna play it again
but it was it was it was horrible that
in and of itself is abusive
this is the document that mr depp signed
the divorce agreement where he says sign
in agreement with his signature neither
party has made false accusations for
financial gain he said that then
he could have fought this then but he
didn't because he knew that her
allegations were true but then he
continued his campaign of humiliation he
says i want her replaced on that wb film
ladies and gentlemen the facts are
absolutely
overwhelming
of abuse one time that's all you have to
remember mr deb simply cannot prove to
you that he never once abused amber and
if you don't
no you have to return a verdict for
misheard a ruling against amber here
sends a message that no matter what you
do
as an abuse victim you always have to do
more no matter what you document you
always have to document more no matter
whom you tell you always have to tell
more people no matter how honest you are
about your own imperfections and your
own shortcomings in a relationship
you need to be perfect in order for
people to believe you
don't send that message
that's what he wants you to send
so i'm going to quickly get to another
point that you have to find in order to
prove
to rule for mr deb you would have to
find that ms heard made the statements
with actual malice now what mr chu
didn't tell you is that you have to find
this by clear and convincing evidence so
this is much higher than the greater
weight of the evidence standard that
applies to the other claims uh the other
elements of the claim clear and
convincing evidence
is evidence
that creates in your minds a firm belief
or conviction that mr depp has proved
this issue so if you believe that miss
heard did not act maliciously in writing
her op-ed then you must return a verdict
or misheard even if you think that he
never abused her
we can i'll quickly go over the evidence
of this that
the op-ed you look at the words it
clearly wasn't a hit piece she visited
her attorney eric george who testified
by video that his objective was to make
sure that there could be no meritorious
claim that could be brought
about this article relating to
defamation he gave miss heard advice she
affirmatively followed all of it so you
cannot find that miss heard met the
clear and convincing evidence standard
given the testimony of eric george given
the testimony of terence doherty from
the aclu when amber went out of her way
to ask her lawyer if it was okay they
will say it doesn't matter if she's
lying
but even if that isn't
um they will say that that doesn't
matter if she's lying but even that
isn't true because again keep in mind
that if misheard wanted to be malicious
toward mr death the article would be
very different and i think it's
interesting here we'll talk about mr
waldman in a second but that amber
utilized her attorney
eric george to make sure that she was
following the law
mr depp used his attorney adam waldman
as an attack dog
to defame amber and to fulfill depp's
promise to her of global humiliation the
last thing i'll touch on before elaine
talks is mr depp's damages the man's at
least consistent in one respect he
blames other people for his problems
everyone but himself
you heard
us reading the stack of articles dating
years before he broke up with amber
before their marriage broke apart
talking about his problems talking about
the fact that his movies were flops
talking about the fact that he was late
to the set he's unreliable as an actor
a word of reminder here ladies and
gentlemen is that the only thing amber
ever did
that mr depp is allowed to sue her for
is the op-ed he's trying to say
i want to sue her for what she said in
2016. i want a sewer for harm that was
caused then you cannot do that the only
thing you're being asked to decide is
are the words of the op-ed defamatory
nothing else
any damage to mr depp's career is
self-caused
then think about the testimony that
you've heard from his former business
manager joel mandel said that dev had
issues with drugs and alcohol that
damaged his career
depp sued him his former agent tracy
jacobs said he was late to the set and
that he used an earpiece
that fired her she said disney never
committed to pirate six
disney's corporate representative tina
newman
said that there was no record in
disney's records of this op-ed this
op-ed had nothing to do with it in fact
katherine arnold our damages expert
testified that the paper
version of the article that allegedly
they say came out four days after the
op-ed was published the same day as the
op-ed that said that johnny might not be
in pirate six
the same day the paper article came out
the same day so the op-ed didn't cause
that
there's no evidence of any contract by
disney for pirate six his agent jack
wiggum couldn't identify a contract his
former agent christian carino said that
there's no contract he didn't lose
anything as a result of this op-ed
anything he's lost is the result of his
own choices
you also heard him lie to you you heard
him tell you that this was his first
chance to tell his story but let's break
it down because that's not true he could
have fought the tro that amber filed he
could have said i didn't abuse her but
he chose not to do that he could have
fought her in the divorce case but he
chose not to do that instead he signed
the statement saying that no one had
falsified any statements
he only filed this suit after he met
adam waldman the same adam waldman who
convinced him to file suit against his
former business manager to file suit
against his law firm and fire them and
blame them for things
but by the time that amber wrote the
op-ed mr def already had had another
opportunity to tell his story
he filed a case in the uk against the
sun
for calling him a wife beater and in
that case he had many of the same
witnesses he was on the stand for parts
of five days and he got to tell the fact
binder in the uk whatever he wanted now
it's not the same testimony told here
because you heard me impeach him about
13 times with his testimony from the uk
but he's had his chances ladies and
gentlemen
it is time to tell mr depp that this was
his last chance
tell him to move on with his life
tell him to let amber move on with hers
stand up for the freedom of speech
stand up for the first amendment
this trial is about so much more than
johnny depp versus amber heard
it's about the freedom of speech
stand up for it protect it and reject mr
depp's claims against amber
and now you'll hear from ms peretta hawt
about the counterclaim
thank you
i got it
i got it yep
i get to say good afternoon
and i know you've been listening to
everybody for a long time here and i
echo ben's
uh very
very
strong thank you to all of you for this
extreme service and extraordinary
service we really appreciate it i'm
going to go really fast
and try to go as quick as i can so that
you can get
a break from us and go make your
decision i know you're probably itching
to do it at this point but this is very
important to us and we appreciate you
listening and we appreciate you being
here
i'm going to stay on this slide for a
moment and there's something that's very
important on this slide that hasn't been
brought to your attention by mr depp's
team
when you see the actual damages go down
to the last paragraph if you will
it says
mr depp
cannot recover damages
for any
harm
that occurred after november to
2020.
do you all see that
so
what mr deb's team got up here and told
you through mr chu this morning
has nothing to do with this case
he had his chance in the uk
he the lot the lawsuit was filed june
2018. six months before the op-ed the
trial was july 2020 the process ended
according to mr mark's their expert
on november 2 2020 and his damages stop
then he can't get reputational damages
he can't get his legacy back for his
children he can't get anything
after that day
from you you can't restore his
reputation you can't give him anything
they didn't tell you that but the court
told you that and that's a very very
important thing here he told his story
he had his opportunities he had his full
opportunities to do all of that and he
came in here and lied to you and said
he's here to get his reputation back
it's just one of many lies in this case
but it's a really big one because here
we are
six weeks of your time precious time six
weeks of this court's time
for what
for nothing
only to go after amber
that's psychological abuse
he's going after amber for nothing
because he wants to put her through this
again
the third time
so we're fighting back and that's the
common claim
she finally has said enough
enough
and we're asking you to finally
hold this man responsible he has never
accepted responsibility for anything in
his life you've heard it this whole time
he hasn't admitted to anything he's
blamed everybody in the world his agent
his manager his lawyer amber his friends
everybody but he's never accepted
responsibility for a thing he's done in
his life but we're asking you to accept
to make him accept responsibility to
hold him legally responsible for his
actions
and to fully and fairly compensate amber
for what he has done
by creating this concept of a hoax for
the defamation that he has committed
that you have heard so much about that
just
took a wildfire and went off into
negative media and has made amber's life
pure hell up to this day we're asking
you to do that to compensate her to to
be fair and hold him responsible so he
stops we don't want another lawsuit we
don't want anything else we want to
leave amber alone and let her get on
with her life and raise her child
so let's talk about the common claim for
a moment
these are adam waldman statements you've
heard mr depp say well why are you why
aren't you suing mr waldman
that isn't that typical of mr depp he
doesn't take responsibility for anything
so now he's going to blame his lawyer
but the evidence is very clear on all
three statements and we'll show them to
you in a minute that he says adam
waldman mr depp's attorney says these
things
now mr deck says oh i didn't even know
about those until the counter claim well
we know that's not true because mr
waldman's testimony was two months
before those statements were made in
february of 2020 mr depp accompanied mr
waldman to the daily mail the same place
that all three of these statements were
published and he gave him two spliced
audio tapes to try to make it look like
amber was the person who was committing
the abuse
he went with him he knew that mr waldman
was doing this he knew that mr waldman
was launching a campaign against amber
to try to discredit her and the timing
of this we're talking the statements now
are april and june of 2020 the trial is
july of 2020 so they're launching an
attack to try to discredit amber before
the trial in the uk that's what happened
here and that is mr waldman but it's mr
depp the judge gave you three different
instructions and you'll all have them
he's acting as his attorney he has the
authority so mr depp is standing in the
shoes of mr waldman mr waldman is
standing in the shoes of mr depp
michelle can you please bring up
the first statement
it says
amber and her friends in the media use
fake sexual violence allegations as both
a sword and shield depending on their
needs they have selected some of her
sexual violence hoax facts as the sword
inflicting them on the public and mr
death
now what this statement is meant to
imply
is that amber is lying about the sexual
assaults
and using them with the media to try to
discredit mr death that's the clear
implications of this now the first part
of this is this contradicts mr depp's
claims today that the first time you
ever heard about the sexual assaults
that happened was in this case it was in
the uk case this is the case that mr
depp brought in the uk
and instead of
amber heard trying to put this out in
the media she did exactly the opposite
now this article is not in your evidence
but at least some of you will remember
it being shown at one point with the
title that said that amber was
successful in being able to treat her
allegations of the sexual violence
confidential in that proceeding and it
was treated confidential she did exactly
the opposite
she didn't want to tell people this and
you know that you watched her understand
it was heart rendering for her to have
to do this
with the cameras no less
but what else is false about this
statement
it's that there was no false statements
of sexual violence ben went through all
four of them and i will not repeat them
all you heard the testimony and
interestingly enough you didn't hear any
stories that differed from that with mr
depp he didn't get on the stand and say
you know no this didn't happen to at
least a couple of them and he can't in
australia he can't remember anything
likely but if you just look at the
pictures of the destruction in that
house i mean imagine
painting those canvases and how long
that took how much hatred and rage you
have to have for somebody to do
something like that writing on the walls
tearing up her nightgown and and
wrapping pieces of raw steak and putting
it all over the house
remember that she also testified that he
took her clothes and swiped them through
all the paint before she left um
you know these things happened um
with respect to the malice on this one
you know he knows
that he did these things you know that
he knows he was out of it for three days
and that's all we need to prove for
males but there's a couple of more facts
here
but you can find whatever mr waldman's
done and you can find
whatever mr depp has done and both of
those are the same for purposes of
evaluating the verdict form they stand
in each other's shoes when you have an
agent and that's what the jury
instructions say you can go with both
what did mr waldman do
there was an article about the sexual
violence that he had put from the april
one that went into the trial amber's
testimony she was sitting near him in
the trial adam waldman threw that
newspaper down in front of her defiantly
that's actually malice
um
and she was quite quite upset and you
heard her testimony on the stand about
that he was just inflicting it on her
remember bruce witkin's testimony this
was johnny depp's best friend for 40
years until he testified truthfully four
years ago
about the drugs and alcohol and he
stopped talking to him there was a
couple of really important things that
bruce witkin said one of the things is
he said he met adam waldman once adam
waldman said do you have any dirt
on the mandels and he said no and that
was it then he didn't care he is an
attack dog all he wants to do is attack
and put dirt on people the second thing
that whitcomb said that i think was
pretty instructive was that
that johnny depp has deep seated anger
issues that have nothing to do with
amber he remembered even back when
johnny was married to his sister-in-law
he had extreme jealousy even back then
and i think that's pretty significant
remember mr richard also was called in a
few times to intercede in some of these
fights between johnny and amber when he
when johnny would become so angry the
last thing i thought he said that was
actually pretty important um was that
kipper and his whole group are a scam he
said you know how is it that they can be
sober sober doctors you know for these
years and he's never sober you know he's
even taking pot all the time how can you
be sober i thought that was quite
instructive but in any event going back
to that's the first statement the second
statement michelle if you can bring that
one up
oh before i go there i want to talk
about a few more things for mr waldman
that you have in your in your
pocket to be able to find additional
analysis with him remember he's the one
that after the uk trial went to the lapd
with a notebook full of things and tried
to get perjury charges against amber
the lapd said we don't investigate those
things
but he then went to a german newspaper
and said amber is being investigated by
the nypd or the lapd for perjury do you
remember that that's malice that's
showing his intent to do harm to amber
he also admitted that he speaks to that
umbrella guy and you'll see that one
text in there from the person from tmz
that umbrella guy is the big lead of
johnny depp's you know positive uh
social media that is putting all the
negative out on amber amber heard uh and
he also ended up getting knocked out of
twitter because he was abusing amber
so now we'll go to the second counter
claim statement
and that is quite simply this was an
ambush a hoax they set mr depp up by
calling the cops but the first attempts
didn't do the trick the officers came to
the penthouses thoroughly searched and
interviewed and left after seeing no
damage to face her property so amber and
her friends spilled a little wine
roughed the place up got their story
straight under the direction of a lawyer
and publicist then place the second call
to 9-1-1
now this is may 21.
now the clear implication here is that
they're saying that amber got together
with their friends they decided they
were going to set johnny up to be
charged for domestic violence and so
they called the police and they tried to
make up this whole story get him
arrested but the police said there's no
evidence here
and went away and they said darn and so
they spilled wine and they you know
busted up the place and they called
9-1-1 they got they got advice from a
lawyer and a publicist called 9-1-1 and
tried again to get johnny charged that's
what this this says now we all know
that's false and it's
heinously false uh because you know
after these events happened and ben
talked about a little bit of it but i'll
talk about the rest of it and i'm going
to try to do it really quickly
but but we all know amber did everything
in her power not to tell them who johnny
was not to press charges not to have him
arrested the exact opposite of this but
what were the facts of may 21st he comes
over he's already been drinking he's
already high and he is on a tear about
feces in the bed from a month ago and
remember how amber talked about when he
gets into these drug
induced things he gets into these
paranoias and he gets some idea in his
head and he just won't let it go
and that was his this time there's
somebody put that feces in the bed a
month ago that was his spin so she gets
iotil it on on the phone he's in new
york at the time he's going they thought
this is ridiculous of course nobody did
and by the way boo has this huge problem
of course it was bo you know he's always
doing this
but johnny just won't get there so then
they laugh that makes him mad then he
throws the phone at amber amber screams
out and says ow you just threw the cell
phone at me it hurts io says amber get
out of there johnny gets madder pulls
her hair grabs her and starts hitting
her
so io gets hold of rocky pennington she
comes over as quickly as she can she
goes and gets in between the two of them
she puts her hands up on his chest he
pushes them down and then she continues
to stand in between them and he's
screaming loudly ten times amber get the
[ __ ] up amber get the [ __ ] up amber get
the [ __ ] up loudly loudly uh then his
his bodyguards hear this they come in
they break it up that's how that happens
but the next part of this remember josh
drew and i think elizabeth mars was
amazing in this one remember their
testimony you know he for after that he
goes and he has to you know he always
leaves a you know path of destruction as
he's leaving so he you know bashes up
things and you saw ben's pictures here
on the picture frames knocks things over
as he's going goes down the hallway he's
splashing the wine he gets his
bodyguards to let him into penthouse
five that's where josh and elizabeth are
trying to help with rocky's bead thing
for the next day and he comes in
storming in and he says get your [ __ ]
out of here and he's got the big magnum
and he's mad and elizabeth is just
terrified she barely knows johnny she's
met him four times and she goes ripping
out of there as fast as she can and josh
gets out of there too then what does he
do
he rearranges the furniture or he might
have knocked something off you know one
of one of the countertops or something i
think is the testimony of his bodyguards
but you saw the pictures he went through
and trashed that place again as he left
now the next part of this is the police
coming
io calls the police he's in new york he
calls the new york police 9-1-1 he's
afraid they're not going to get there
fast enough he still remembers december
15 because he came in afterwards and saw
all of the injuries on amber and all the
evidence
and he's terrified that amber's still in
there the police have in common that
johnny's going to kill her so he calls a
friend in la and says please call 9-1-1
we got to get somebody there fast so she
calls 911. so we have two calls and
you'll see the call summary and the call
summary shows those two calls
really close
in proximity here so it's not them uh oh
we didn't get the first police officer
so we'll rough up the place and make a
second one you'll see that they're like
eight minutes apart uh up there but it
took two hours to dispatch the two
different ones and amber never even had
any idea that the second one was coming
the first ones come and you know we've
talked about it we've shown you the
pictures the police officers admitted
that those pictures could could very
much have been what was there that night
remember officer hadden it was his first
week on the job officer science was
three three years on the job at that
point they say you know they told josh
that if she will press charges if she'll
give a name we can file a report and
make an arrest she wouldn't do it you
did hear from detective santana that's
the domestic violence
you recall josh drew saying that the
police officer told him you know she'll
give a name we'll make an arrest he
definitely said that um but in any event
she would not
she would not cooperate she didn't want
to but but detective santana their
domestic relations or domestic violence
person
said they should have
done an incident report no matter what
even if they decided there wasn't a
crime because domestic violence has the
cycles they come back and it's good to
have the record for the next time that
it might happen so she said they should
have under the circumstances even if
they didn't and she also said that when
they put verbal dispute only in those
calls it is a code that they use and
you'll see that it's twice on that call
report so they to to say that's why we
didn't write a report um but in any way
whether the police officers you know
forgot about it two months later when
they were first asked about it whether
they just decided she's never going to
press charges and you'll see on the call
report they're insisting that to the
second set it doesn't make any
difference the point is this is still
false this statement is still false
because amber did everything but try to
press charges against johnny depp so
they go away
and the testimony is that josh and amber
and rocky cleaned up because they have
dogs so they cleaned up a lot of the
glass and the wine
and those types they had no idea the
second police officers were coming by
and they certainly didn't call them and
they certainly didn't they never talked
to a publicist she did talk to a lawyer
who gave her advice and that's why she
wouldn't tell them you know anything she
said i'm not going to cooperate at all
um so the second one's coming you saw
that you've got the video cameras in
there you see there's no effort by them
to try to get now these officers to
press charges against johnny depp just
the opposite josh drew doesn't want to
even let him in the place
they come through quickly everything's
fine they wave everything's fine are
they trying to press charges against
johnny no they're not trying to do
anything they're trying to get him out
of there which makes this statement a
hundred percent false was it made with
malice absolutely there's nobody that
thinks that amber tried to press charges
that night johnny knew that but the
other thing that's very helpful and what
you should look at is defendants exhibit
772 and 773 because once again the next
day
johnny apologizes to amber he says in
two different text messages that 772 and
773
he says my profound apologies in one of
them and my apologies are eternal in the
other one what is he apologizing for the
next day on may 22nd if he didn't know
that he did all of those things and by
the way remember isaac
baruch even remembers the wine in the
hallway the police none of the police
officers remember the wine and that's
because they're busy and they got a
zillion other things going and they
didn't remember this call two months
later when they were asked about it
uh so that's that's the next one um so
clearly that's 100 percent false clearly
they knew it clearly there's malice in
making that statement they're trying to
suggest that she's manufacturing
evidence with her friends to try to
frame mr deb
nothing could be further from the truth
on that one and there's not she did not
want those police officers to press
charges now let's go to the third one
oh and let's talk about the makeup just
for a moment while we're going to the
third one this makeup thing fresh face
natural these were adam waldman planting
these when he when he talked to the ecb
people you remember the testimony here
we kept asking so did you talk to mr
walton did you talk to mr waltman mr
waldman was trying to plant in all of
these people's objection your honor
somehow
she wasn't
he approached
so i didn't say that any of the
witnesses admitted that adam walton
planted that i'm saying he planted it
that's me arguing in the planting and
that's because it's all the same thing
she wasn't wearing any makeup she was
natural she wasn't wearing a stitch of
makeup every one of them says it's the
exact same thing well why would you say
that she's an actor she's not going to
go outside her house you know without
putting makeup on and if she has bruises
why on earth when she's been covering
them up for four years why on earth
would she not put makeup on so that she
would cover those up
why on earth would she not want to cover
up those bruises it makes no sense but
you know what you guys saw her here you
guys sorry um
you saw amber on the stand there were
days where she didn't wear eye makeup
a lot of people think that she's not
wearing makeup when she doesn't have
mascara
and eyeliner on she has different looks
and some of them are with eye makeup and
some of them are without and people
misunderstand especially people that
aren't that good at makeup and a lot of
men frankly um go oh that's then she
probably doesn't have makeup and that's
where that mistake happens but you heard
her testimony and you heard her makeup
artist testimony saying she doesn't go
out of her room without concealer and
foundation she knows how to put these
things in and you saw defendants exhibit
155 and you'll have the actual thing in
there that's the type of palette she
used and she was very adept at telling
you what color she puts on for the
different days of bruises this is a
woman who for four years did everything
she could to cover up anybody knowing
anything about this abuse do you
honestly think she's just going to walk
around for the week with her bruises
exposed of course she's not
now
let's go to the third one
and this is
the abuse hoax
he says we've reached the beginning of
the end of ms hurd's abuse hoax against
johnny depp
now the the obviously the defamatory
meaning of that is that amber's creating
an abuse hoax but there is no abuse hoax
i don't need to tell you all of the
evidence because ben did a beautiful job
of just taking you through all of those
different things but i will point out a
couple things for you and that is
remember bonnie jacobs the therapist
dr hughes and dr spiegel testified about
bonnie jacobs notes and remember that i
was holding that you don't get to see
them but they testified that they went
through them dr hughes testified that
she also spoke with bonnie jacobs she
kept contemporaneous notes from 2011
when she first started seeing amber and
the abuse is documented in those notes
is what dr hughes testified to they
start in 2012. both physical
objection your honor that doctor
so dr hughes specifically characterized
dr
dr jabani jacob's notes as reflecting
both contemporaneous physical abuse and
sexual abuse throughout that time period
dr spiegel confirmed that later and said
the same when i asked dr curry if she
had reviewed those notes she said yes
but she had no comment your honor
objection
um
confirmed that he had reviewed bonnie
jacobs notes as well and when i asked dr
curry she said she had reviewed them but
she had no comment but she also didn't
deny that those were in there amber
heard testified that she went back and
because of bonnie jacobs notes she
realized for the first time that the
abuse started much earlier than she even
realized before she always had thought
that it it started in 2013.
when she went back and saw bonnie jacobs
notes she realized that it had started
much earlier and she was very
embarrassed by that now significantly
you remember that she testified about
how she went and she was first called
upon to actually detail all of her
events of abuse in february of this year
and she went through and took the notes
took photos to you she took everything
she had calendars everything put it all
together and you heard about at least 64
pages
of detail
accountability of that and mr depp's
team has been able to not refute any of
that remember they tried to impeach her
and say well you didn't say that she
said yes i did on page 64. remember that
it was a very very difficult process for
her because there was an awful lot of it
and she put it in great detail
now
let's talk for a moment about the motive
they have said that she has created this
whole hoax and i think ben's done a nice
job of showing how that can't possibly
have been
but what would amber heard's motive be
for creating a hoax or creating any of
this or making any of this up that's a
big question here they call her a gold
digger right but she obviously couldn't
have done it for the money because first
of all remember the testimony of laura
wasser the divorce attorney
she said that
california is a no fault state and
community property so amber doesn't have
to have an abuse
she she could have
she could have divorced him for
irreconcilable differences for
abandonment for adultery for anything
she doesn't need an excuse and she gets
fifty percent of whatever he earns
during the time of the marriage unless
they had a prenup or a post note the
testimony from michelle mulrooney was
that amber completely cooperated with
the prenup and the post nut but it was
johnny depp who and you've already heard
from ben he called her up and fired her
he didn't want a post nut or a prenup so
she's entitled to fifty percent of
everything he he owe he earns during
that time now we have plaintiffs exhibit
936 in evidence and look at page 69 it
says how much he made in 2015. it was 43
million remember that mr spindler dep's
expert who said that he made 22 million
in 2016. so you got 65 million dollars
amber was entitled to 31.5 at least that
doesn't include all the back ends from
for example pirates five she was
entitled to that money
so she didn't need to say anything she
could have just said i don't like you
anymore i don't like the color of your
hair i'm going to divorce you your honor
we're going to object again
so if you do the math amber is entitled
at least 31.5 what does she take 7
million what does she do with the seven
million she gives it to charity or she
intends to give it to charity now they
make much ado about the pledge versus
donation but both the corporate
designees for aclu and for children's
hospital said donation and pledge are
interchangeable these are pledges the
aclu corporate designee said you
typically do pledges because of the tax
benefits and that's what she said she
pledged it over a period of time because
of the tax implications to it and
because she was getting paid over the
time now she started to make these
donations and you'll see that the first
one was on behalf of mr depp's uh
business manager mr white actually sent
the letters with the hundred thousand
for each of those that was the initial
ones
he was trying to take credit for those
and in fact both the aclu and children's
hospital got confused and gave the
credit to mr dappnock to amber for those
then she made payments to both and elon
musk also made payments to both for 500
000 each which she didn't count to her
pledge but they helped those
organizations at the end of the day
she's made a million dollars in pledge
in payments to them but then she got
sued here and hasn't been able to
because she spent six million dollars in
attorney's fees that is unrefuted she
still intends to pay those pledges honor
those pledges and she said that
throughout and i elicited from both the
aclu and from children's hospital they
haven't expired she can pay them
whenever she wants to and she fully
intends to but she has to get out from
under this first
now who would accu who would blame a
woman for giving a million dollars in in
charitable donations who would do that
that sounds like psychological abuse to
me now mr mandel testified that johnny
depp is not a charitable person and he
hasn't written any big checks for him mr
depp got on the stand and says he does
it unanimously
anonymously
but mr mandel would have been the one
writing the checks and he says that
didn't happen
now let's go to damages because
i promised you i was going to go pretty
fast here
um
there's a few different types of damages
but one of the things that the court has
talked to you about she she told you
that because we have defamation it's
invidious and therefore it's very
difficult to prove these and so
these damages to business reputation
inconvenience embarrassment are presumed
you don't have to prove those damages
and one great example of that is the
testimony from mr hamada at warner
brothers he didn't want to have to get
in the middle of all of this with
aquaman 2 they haven't even released it
so he didn't read anything in
preparation for his deposition he didn't
talk to anybody before his deposition he
said that he tried to do technicals and
say no we never terminated her contract
but oh yeah we did tell her we were
probably not going to renew her option
um and then we didn't change the script
but and we got the script and yes they
did change it then he said um you know
no we never negotiate salaries but oh
yeah we did negotiate read and negotiate
jason mahmoud and gal gadot's so he just
doesn't want to admit to any of these
things but what came out in hamada's
deposition and i hope you were listening
carefully to this was the email from
james wand the director and jane and
jason momoa her co-star who said they
guarantee if they are in the film she is
going to be mirror in the film why would
they do that unless they thought warner
brothers was being unfair to her and why
did she get almost knocked out of it
because of the defamatory statements
when they came out they took on a life
of their own ron schnell that the young
sheldon i call him her the doogie houser
our expert on i.t took you through and
tracked how they tracked the defamatory
statements the language from the
defamatory statements how that went
through the social media and the
negative social media uh and it kept
going and kept going and he tracked all
the way until a few months ago over 2.36
million negative tweets negative
instagrams negative social medias
comments about amber that relates
specifically to the in the information
that was in those three defamatory
statements it took on a life of its own
they started to get amber fired from
aquaman two they have continued to this
day they have followed her everywhere
everybody has stopped wanting her
l'oreal won't use her even though
they've kept her on from that time she
lost three different opportunities that
were being discussed with her the most
significant part of that though is that
aquaman was the biggest blockbuster ever
for dc films it was the biggest it was
over a billion dollars this was her
opportunity for her star even the
experts from mr depp admitted this was
her blockbuster this was her mega but
what happened instead as she's going
through as it's coming out and in that
16 months they were going well nothing
happened yeah lots happened she was had
three different films she was discussing
she had she got the l'oreal contract she
she got the stand all of those things
were happening because of aquaman and
then everything shut down she wasn't
allowed to do publicity for the stand
she wasn't allowed to uh she you know
hasn't been allowed to do anything for
l'oreal she got shut down from her
charitable organizations she she ended
up not getting the amazon movie and then
they gave her a hard time about aquaman
two and instead of the career trajectory
of the other comparators who all went
way up and by the way all the experts
admit
that that career trajectory went well
for all the rest of them and she's the
only one that didn't have it and the
reason is because of the defamatory
statements so you have some very good
information to help you on on
ascertaining those damages now jessica
kovachevich
and i don't know if you remember her but
she was her agent she said everybody
just stopped talking the producers don't
want her the directors don't want her
nobody wants it we just can't get the
traction and we should have been able to
get the traction and they say it's
because of those statements so catherine
arnold
gave you
some good estimates on this and she gave
you a very good basis for it and she
didn't use jason momoa's or gal gadot's
or the others she used amber's but used
those comparators to show that they got
big movies that they got commercial
opportunities that they got these tv
opportunities but she used the base that
amber had so she used the four million
from the aquaman that would be three she
used the the stands you know how much
they got paid per movie and what she
estimated on those and she went through
those details is that if you took that
for the last two years and projected
into the next three to four that it's
between 47 and 50 million dollars that
she could have had instead of her star
being completely extinguished and that's
what's happened to her the emotional
distress damages
are even more extreme here
and that is don hughes testified
extensively about the ptsd and what she
goes through and every time she's called
a liar every time these hoax things come
up everything it causes her to relive
all of it she talks about the panic
attacks the nervousness the intrusive
thoughts the nightmares all of the the
sweats the you know the anxiety that
goes through all of this uh it's it's
significant but probably the most
compelling testimony that you could ever
hear was from amber yesterday and when
she took the stand before
it has destroyed her life this has
consumed her she's getting death threats
her daughter they're threatening to put
her daughter in a microwave for god
sakes she can't get away from this it's
everywhere this media the social media
that has just taken off has just
consumed her life as she said i'm a
human being
no human being should be put through
this
now johnny depp sued
for 100 million for 50 million dollars
and we sent the message back saying fine
and we're going to sue for 100 million
because look at what you've done to her
we're not we're not asking you to give a
hundred million dollars we're asking you
to just look at the damages in this case
and just be fair and reasonable in
whatever you determine by following the
evidence and the instructions but we do
ask that you fully and fairly compensate
amber for everything that she's been
through both in terms of reputation and
emotional distress the very last point
is punitive damages and you surely have
those in this case we've asked for 350
000 for the punitive damages and we
would ask that you award that
thank you very much
thank you
all right ladies and gentlemen what i'm
going to do um
we still have rebuttal closing arguments
but i can guarantee you that the
rebuttal
closing arguments will be done combined
within 45 minutes but what i want to do
is go ahead and let you have your lunch
and then after lunch we'll come back in
the courtroom have the rebuttal closing
arguments and then we'll submit the case
to you okay
all right so go ahead and have your
lunch do not discuss the case with each
other and do not do any outside research
okay
all right
so let's let's come back at 210.
um and
just for the record uh plaintiff's at 39
minutes left for a bottle
defendants have six minutes
okay
i didn't take any time off from the
sidebar it's zero off from the sidebars
it's all from testimony okay all right
thank you
all right
ready for the jury
okay
hmm
oh
all right
thank you ladies and gentlemen you may
be seated all right rebuttal arguments
hello
good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
miss hurt's counsel has mischaracterized
the record multiple times
and this heard lied to you
they've mischaracterized the testimony
of police officer signs and hadden
who explicitly testified that they saw
no signs of injury and no property
damage they mischaracterized the
testimony of walter hamada
who testified clearly that there was no
impact on misheard's career at aquaman 2
from anything said by adam waldman or
johnny depp
and miss herd's casting was delayed
because of creative issues
they've mischaracterized the testimony
of detective sadaga
they mischaracterized the testimony of
ronald shell
you've been here you've listened to the
testimony you know the record
ms heard lied and she lied again and she
kept lying
she lied six years ago
on may 27 2016 when she walked into
court in los angeles to publicly accuse
mr depp of abuse for the first time
she lied again when she told the world
over and over again that she donated all
of the seven million dollars divorce
settlement to charity
you heard the evidence that about what
she donated and you watched her you
watched her try to save her life about
that broken promise with more lies on
the stand in this courtroom
she lied again when she told the world
in her op-ed on december 18 2018 that
she was a public figure representing
domestic abuse
painting herself as a representative of
abuse survivors everywhere and painting
mr depp as a representative of
perpetrators
she's come too far
she can't back down
she's lied too many times to too many
people
so when mr depp
finally decided to fight to clear his
name by filing this lawsuit miss heard
responded by making up more and more
stories of more and more extreme abuse
she came up with a new accusation that
mr depp had raped her with a bottle in
australia
and she keeps making new claims up even
now
at this trial for the very first time
she claimed
that she had been sexually assaulted the
night of her 30th birthday even though
she had testified repeatedly about her
birthday prior
and never mentioned it
and at this trial she also claimed for
the very first time that mr depp was
hitting her all the time during the
first year of their relationship even
though this first year she had testified
previously
was magic and bliss
with absolutely no violence
her story is a constantly moving target
it never stays the same
mr depp owns his mistake
he owns all of them
you saw him do it on the stand in a raw
and powerful way
but in this trial miss heard has been
confronted with her lies and the damage
she has caused
and she cannot take any responsibility
for what she has done
and you've seen the story her story it
doesn't hold up
you've watched her performance on the
stand
you saw her get caught in lie after lie
the time has come for those lies to come
to an end the time has come for you the
jury to decide the truth
i started this
trial
giving you an opening statement and i
said to you that words matter
and this case is about ms heard's words
the words she published in an op-ed
about mr depp
ms hurd and her attorneys have talked a
lot about
in this trial about the first amendment
they've talked about the importance of
free speech
and we agree
i'm a lawyer of course i agree with that
but the first amendment doesn't protect
lies that hurt and defame people and
there's a difference
misheard has no right to tell the world
that mr depp physically or sexually
assaulted her
when that isn't true
that's not protected speech
our u.s constitution doesn't protect
that speech
and it is a core value of american
society that you are innocent until
proven guilty there are there is a
presumption of innocence in this country
a person's life cannot and should not be
destroyed by a baseless charge and no
opportunity to defend yourself
that's why mr depp had to bring this
claim
ms hurd was never going to stop calling
him an abuser the only way to clear his
name was to stand up in this court where
both sides are bound by the same rules
of american law
a jury would be tasked you ladies and
gentlemen would be tasked with deciding
once and for all
miss hurt's lies could be exposed in a
fair and impartial process
when mr depp sued her ms hurd apparently
decided she needed to sue him back
and because there were no statements
made by mr depp on which she could base
the claim she sued him based on
statements made by one of his lawyers
adam waldman
calling ms hurd's accusations of abuse a
hoax
make no mistake though they are a hoax
miss heard made up claims of abuse and
then she gave a performance where she
passionately repeated those made up
claims of abuse on the stand in front of
each of you
but ask yourselves who's really the one
alleging a hoax here
who wants you to believe that everyone
else is lying
committing perjury
ms heard needs you to believe that all
the people who showed up in this
courtroom to testify on behalf of mr deb
they're all lying
she needs you to believe that the
witnesses you heard from including
security professionals former
cops
medical professionals and police
officers they're all lying
covering up for mr depp
she's asking you to believe that she's
the one telling the truth and that the
rest of the people in mr duff's life are
all part of a conspiracy of silence
this case is not just about whether you
believe mr depp or you believe miss
heard this case is about whether you
believe miss heard or whether you
believe mr depp christy dembrowski who
yes is here supporting her brother
isaac baroosh who weeped in front of the
world
keenan wyatt
who doesn't work for mr death sean betts
a former la sheriff's department
malcolm connolly he worked in the
prisons in the uk
starling jenkins a former us marine
travis mcgivern
also another former police officer ben
king he worked for the queen of england
david kipper dr david kipper
miss heard's doctor and yes mr depp's
doctor
debbie lloyd a nurse aaron fellotti ms
hurd's personal nurse
officer signs an la police officer with
training and domestic violence
officer hadden her understudy
yes in his first week
studying to to pick up on these signs of
domestic abuse
officer gatlin
brandon patterson who worked at eastern
columbia building
kate james miss herd's former personal
assistant tara roberts
alejandro romero
he took his deposition from his car
because he had to go to work
but didn't stop him from telling the
truth
edward white mr depp's business manager
laura wasser one of the most famous
divorce lawyers in california
morgan knight
beverly leonard
morgan tremaine
and kate moss
and all the other witnesses whose
stories support mr death's description
of what took place
these people have nothing to gain by
coming forward
they have everything to lose
you have seen mr waldman's statements
and evidence in this case
when you look at them you can tell that
the key point mr waldman was making in
each of these statements was simply that
miss heard's accusations against mr depp
were lies
that's why he talks about an abuse hoax
now mr has the burden of proof of
proving that mr waldman's statements are
false
and that means that miss herta has to do
more than prove that mr waldman got some
details wrong
she has to prove that mr waldman's
statements are false in their essential
meaning
in other words she has to prove that her
abuse claims are not a hoax
but as we've seen the evidence is
overwhelming that ms hurt's claims of
abuse are false
we should also spend a bit of time
talking about actual malice
it is ms heard's burden to prove that mr
waldman's statements were made with
actual malice
an actual malice means
knowledge that the statements were false
or
reckless
and that's an important word reckless
disregard for the truth
but here
there is clear evidence that mr waldman
genuinely believed that miss heard had
committed a hoax
you watched him give the testimony by
deposition in this case he testified
about the evidence he found persuasive
the numerous witnesses and the sworn
depositions of the police officers
who went to the penthouses that night
and again saw no injuries
there is no evidence in this record none
that mr waldman acted with actual malice
he believed
mr deb he believed the record
it's also important to understand that
because mr waldman's statements were not
made by mr depp ms hurd needs to prove
that mr waldman was acting as mr death's
agent
and within the scope of that agency
within the scope of the agency of the
employment when he made the statements
mr waldman is a lawyer
matured has not presented evidence that
making those statements was part of mr
waldman's responsibilities as mr depp's
lawyer
there's nothing in the record
ms hurd is also claiming to be suffering
from ptsd and claims that she has
something to do with mr waldman's
statements
ms hurd wants you to believe that she
suffers from ptsd because mr depp
purportedly abused her but as usual miss
hurt is not telling the truth
as you heard from dr shannon curry miss
her does not have ptsd and she does not
act like a person with ptsd
ms hurt is an actress in a major film
involved in sommelier training she just
had a baby
dr curry also found that ms hurt
attempted to grossly exaggerate her
symptoms during testing which is a sign
of malingering
or said differently i've misheard lying
ms heard hired dr don hughes to help her
with this narrative
dr hughes did not catch ms hurd's
exaggeration during testing because dr
hughes used an improper malingering
screen test
she wasn't going to find it one that is
meant to identify an examinee's attempt
to fake a severe mental illness or
psychosis
not ptsd
dr hughes diagnosed ms heard with ptsd
without administering the gold standard
diagnostic test
used for ptsd
she diagnosed her think about that she
diagnosed her with ptsd before
administering the tests she admitted was
the gold standard
two years after diagnosing was heard
with ptsd
and shortly curiously shortly after dr
curry administered the gold standard
diagnostic test
in her evaluation of misheard but before
it was disclosed
dr hughes decided to administer the gold
standard finally
nevertheless even after dr hughes used
the proper test there were a number of
deficiencies in her administration of
that test
you saw them
including her failure to even follow the
instructions that render her diagnosis
unreliable
ms hurt's claim for monetary damages
related to mr waldman's statements
frankly it's a it's a fantasy
misheard speculates wildly that she has
somehow been damaged by mr waldman's
statements but in reality miss hurt has
not shown any damage at all that was
because of or by mr waldman's statements
there is an evidence there is evidence
of a mountain of negative press coverage
about misheard including press reports
about her defecating mr duff's bed
cutting off his finger and putting out a
cigarette on his face
but none of that has anything to do with
mr waldman's statements
and ms hurd has presented no evidence
none
of any film
or other project that she has lost
lost
because of the statements
in fact you heard from warner brothers
president walter hamada who explained
that misheard suffered no loss
none
no loss of compensation or other adverse
effect on her major film aquaman 2.
you heard it straight from him
mr expert catherine arnold testified
but for the statements from mr waldman
miss heard would be a much more
successful in her career
to form this opinion ms arnold compares
miss heard to actors such as jason momoa
the actual aquaman
chris pine
gal gadot
and zendaya
but as richard marx who does deals every
day that's his job not testifying here
for a paycheck
does deals
in hollywood
and doug banya both testified that these
actors are simply not comparable to miss
hurt
after all jason momoa he was aquaman
chris pine he was captain kirk
gal gadot
wonder woman
zendaya she's been acting since she was
13 years old on the disney channel
and she's in every single spider-man
movie
further the q scores of these actors are
not at all comparable with ms heard's q
scores as mr bonya testified miss hurt's
rating was less compared to these actors
and all of mrexcue scores ratings were
less favorable than the average of all
performers
as you heard from michael spindler
because miss arnold relies on the
salaries of these comparable actors to
calculate misheard's damages miss hurt's
claim for damages makes no sense
there's no connection
further and more fatally from his herds
damages claim
is that there's no connection to the
waldman statements to mr waldman's
statements
even if you find damage
to her career you have to connect it to
the defamatory statements
there is no connection
mr banya testified that all the negative
tweets that misheard has entered into
evidence have no causal connection to
the statement's underlying misheard's
counterclaims
specifically mrs hurd's expert mr ron
shell
presented a flawed methodology that
included picking out hashtags at random
including justice for johnny depp
what does that have to do with the
waldman statements
and counting accompanying tweets even
though it had nothing to do with mr
waldman
miss hurt's counterclaim is based on
statements by mr wolven not mr depp
ms heard knows perfectly well that she
hasn't suffered any damages from those
statements
buried at the bottom of articles in a
mere tabloid the daily mail
and the statements are substantially
true since they all since all they do
really is point out that misheard's
abuse allegations are false
maturity's counsel argued that mature
did not write the title of the online
version of the op-ed which stated i
spoke up against sexual violence and
faced our culture's wrath that has to
change
does not matter
whether or not ms hurd wrote the title
you will recall from the court's
instructions this morning that what
matters is whether miss heard
republished the defamatory language
that instruction states in part that you
should find ms heard republish this
article if she quote re-transmitted the
defamatory material with the goal of
achieving a new audience stated
differently
republication occurs when the speaker
has affirmatively
that's important affirmatively
reiterated the statement
ms heard affirmatively reiterated the
statement she posted it on her twitter
if we could please pull up plaintiff's
exhibit 3.
this is the tweet ms heard sent
she retweeted the washington post tweet
to a new audience her own twitter
followers
and she affirmatively reiterated the
statement by proudly declaring
today i published this op-ed in the
washington post
she didn't quibble
with the title
she said proudly today i published
this op-ed in the washington post
the title of the op-ed was prominently
displayed in the tweet
that is enough for you members of the
jury to find that ms heard republished
the title of the op-ed and adopted the
statement as her own she can and should
be held liable and responsible for that
statement
ms hurd tries to make something out of
the fact that mr waldman reported her to
law enforcement in los angeles for
perjury after her allegations of abuse
were made
against mr depp
but i'll submit to you that all this
proves is that mr waldman believes miss
hurd has committed perjury
mr ronborne argued that the lack of
supporting evidence from ms heard's
allegations of horrendous constant abuse
is somehow not something to be
considered
that it is shameful
for you to consider the fact that she
didn't document all the terrible
injuries that she claims to have
suffered
that is a twisted argument
first you know because you have seen and
listened to misheard in action that
misheard is a woman who's documenting
things throughout the relationship
and it is instructive that the things
she chose to document had nothing to do
with violence
she documented mr depp's sleeping
she documented lines of cocaine
featuring prominently mr depp's loan out
company or
production company infinitum
stage photographs that's what she
documented
mr rottenborn's entire argument assumes
that mr depp a man should be disbelieved
because
despite the fact that ms hurd can't
support her accusations with actual
evidence
what we have put to you the jury
is not that because miss heard didn't
take enough pictures or tell people
about abuse that it didn't happen
what we have put to you is that given
how brutal
and constant the abuse misheard claims
she would have had serious injuries
that's a fact
she would have had serious injuries
that would have been observable in the
pictures we looked at and by the
witnesses we heard from
and would have required medical
attention
that's it
mr testifies to injuries that multiple
people didn't see
what you have in the end is misheard's
word
do you trust it
we are not here because miss heard told
the world mr death was verbally abusive
this is not about
the words used by mr deb
we are here because ms hurd told the
world that mr depp was physically and
sexually abusive
that's what miss heard was saying in the
op-ed on may 27th exactly six years ago
today
2016 miss heard walked into court with a
mark on her face to tell the world that
her husband was abusive
she renewed that falsehood in her op-ed
describing herself as a public figure
representing domestic abuse and she
published the op-ed including the title
claiming that she spoke up against
sexual violence
everyone
everyone knew who she was talking about
when she used those words
she was alleging physical and sexual
abuse
she was not alleging
emotional or psychological abuse she was
alleging physical and sexual abuse
miss her cannot run away from her own
allegations now you have all heard the
evidence of what she alleged against mr
death in 2016. and you have all heard
her incredibly dramatic over-the-top
story of physical and sexual abuse
that story was a defamatory lie
mature tried to argue that you only need
to find that mr deb might have touched
miss heard once in order to find in her
favor because that makes her a victim of
abuse
but common sense should tell you that
you can't pick and choose miss heard's
allegations
you saw her on the stand
we all did
she gave the performance of her life
telling you story after story of abuse
and not just any abuse but extravagant
over-the-top allegations of abuse that
would be truly brutal
horrific if true
you either believe all of it
or you believe none of it
either she's telling the truth
including in her most extreme
allegations
or she's lying
either she was raped by a bottle
or she's the sort of person who would
get on the stand in this courtroom
and lie to you and the world about being
raped
and if she would lie about that
what would she lie about
you can't find that mr depp hit her once
either he hit her countless times or you
can't believe a single word that comes
out of her mouth
and what is the actual meaning of
misheard's op-ed
that's an important question
it's not that mr depp said a nasty word
to her once
it's not that mr depp might have hit her
once
it's that she is a representative
of domestic abuse and by extension mr
depp is a representative of abuse
perpetrators
words matter
ms hurt has shown you a lot of text
messages from mr deb with some very
vivid language
as i told you at the start of this trial
mr depp has a unique style of writing
he uses words i don't use
and you probably don't use either
but as you also heard during this trial
mr depp writes in that way in part
because he modeled his writings on
literary giants like hunter s thompson
and he's got a dark sense of humor
it's not everyone's cup of tea
but it's who he is
and mr depp owns text messages he
acknowledges that he said those things
and he said things that he shouldn't
have
but using bad language and colorful
humor does not mean that you are a
violent abuser
and ironically as much as miss hurt is
trying to use mr death's words against
him it is misheard who repeatedly
admitted to violence
in her own words
you've heard the tapes you've heard her
admit to
violence miss hurt can try to distract
you with text messages showing that mr
depp uses bad language and has a dark
sense of humor but none of that i submit
to you ladies and gentlemen none of that
is evidence of abuse
hitting your husband is evidence of
abuse
mr ronborne talked about the burden of
proof
let's talk about that for a minute
mr depp only has to show that it is more
likely than not
more likely than not that the statements
in the op-ed are false
that it is more likely than not that
they have a defamatory implication
that it is more likely than not that ms
heard designed and intended the
statements to refer to mr depp
and the evidence on this on these points
is clear
miss heard made these allegations six
years ago today
may 27 2016.
she went out of her way to make them
public
tipping off tmz
when she published the op-ed she was
reminding everyone in hollywood and the
world
of her abuse claims
and those claims are a lie
consider what the true purpose of the
article
mr ronborne said it was to promote
legislative
reforms but what was it actually
the evidence shows it was to promote
misheard
it was time to be released at the same
time as aquaman on december 21 2018
and it was time to coincide with her
announcement of her ambassadorship at
the aclu for women's rights
that's not a coincidence it was designed
that way
that was not a statement about
legislative reforms
this was about
burnishing miss herd's reputation at the
expense of mr depp's
it was about miss heard continuing to
portray herself as a heroic survivor of
abuse
and on the question of actual malice
that just means whether or not misheard
knew the allegations were false
misheard
knows perfectly well that she wasn't
abused
she has direct knowledge of that she was
in that relationship
so actual malice is easily established
you may have noticed that no one showed
up for miss hurt in this courtroom other
than her sister
every other witness who traveled to
virginia for her was a paid expert
this is a woman who burns bridges
her close friends don't show up for her
mr rottenborn tried to discredit mr
depp's witnesses by suggesting they're
all on mr depp's payroll so he doubled
down on the hoax theory that everyone's
just lying
first of all it's not even true keenan
wyatt isn't is on his payroll
ben king isn't on his payroll melissa
officer melissa science isn't on his
payroll morgan tremaine
isn't on his payroll officer tyler
hadden he's not on his payroll beverly
leonard
alejandro romero
brandon patterson
morgan knight
none of those people are on his payroll
and kate moss
kate moss is most definitely not on mr
depp's payroll
ms heard wants you to believe that all
these people are lying
let's talk about the boston plane
ms heard wants you to believe that the
recording you heard is from the boston
plane flight
but that's quite telling
what did miss hurt capture of this
supposed rampage
mr debt moaning in distress
that's what she chose to record
what sort of person records something
like that
sort of person takes pictures of their
husband or boyfriend or fiance who's
struggling with sobriety
nodding off
with ice cream dripping down his leg
his hand in his
pocket or sleep on the ground
what sort of person does that
definitely not someone that's afraid of
him
and ms heard's attorney told the story
of may 21 that was completely
utterly inconsistent
with the testimonies of officer for sir
signs and haddon who testified clearly
that they saw no signs of injury
no sign of property damage
and she told a story about how officer
saddam
sadanaga's testimony was also wrong she
testified that the report was only
required in case of a crime miss hurd's
attorneys tried to tell you that mr depp
apologized on may 22nd because he had
hit and misheard
mr depp didn't apologize to miss hurd on
may 22nd for hitting her he apologized
because he was leaving miss heard
and this was a woman that in spite of
all her violence and all her rage mr
depp he loved her
he had been with her for years
of course he apologized when he finally
broke it off
miss bretoff also tried to tell you that
miss her did everything in her power to
keep the authorities away
and to not get mr depp in trouble on may
21 2016
take a minute and think back to what
miss her did six days later six years
ago today
she walked into court with a visible
mark on her face
not wearing makeup that day
she tipped off tmz
she made it public and she showed up on
the cover of people magazine with a mark
on her face
is that protecting mr depp
or was she trying to destroy him
mr ronborne asked you to consider why
you're here
so why are you here
you're here because of a lie
and that was a lie that misheard
repeated in the op-ed
at the start of this trial
we told you that this trial is about the
evidence
the evidence overwhelmingly shows that
ms heard is an abuser
and that she is a liar
she lied about mr depp and took on the
role of a lifetime as a public figure
representing domestic abuse
what is her best evidence
of that abuse
a video of mr depp
banging cabinets around
and text messages of mr depp using bad
words and dark ugly humor
but never once admitting to abuse
pictures of mr depp sleeping
that's her best evidence
ms heard herself
ms heard held herself out to the world
as a representative of abused survivors
everywhere
the face of the metoo movement
this is not a me too situation
there are no me too's
just not knees
ms hurd does not deserve to be known as
a representative of survivors of abuse
and mr depp does not deserve to be known
as the representative of perpetrators of
abuse
that is what this case is about it's not
about money
it's about giving mr deb his life back
six years ago when she took it away
while you deliberate
ask yourselves why mr depp would put
himself through this
expose every embarrassing detail of his
life on national television
if he was guilty of anything anything
that ms hurt accuses him of
we ask you we implore you
to render a verdict for mr deb
we ask you to set the record straight
that he is not the abuser she described
and that she is not the heroic survivor
she portrayed
and we ask you to tell ms heard that
what she did was wrong
thank you very much ladies and gentlemen
thank you ma'am
rebuttal closing
how about that yes thank you
ladies and gentlemen it's interesting
that in both their opening in the
rebuttal closing that you heard mr
depp's attorneys address
none of ms heard's witnesses none of
misheard's witnesses they listed their
own who didn't see
who are on his payroll weren't there
behind closed doors with them but they
didn't address any of the witnesses for
example josh drew rocky pennington liz
mars who were all there on may 21st
melanie iglesias who covered miss
heard's bruises they say that no one
showed up for her
no one showed up for her but then they
say that these people aren't friends
anymore if they're not friends anymore
then why would they be doing what they
would suggest are lying for her why
would they be corroborating everything
that she says
if
it's this simple
if you believe that depp was abusive to
amber one time ever in any of the
various forms of abuse
not only physical verbal emotional
psychological sexual any of the ways of
abuse then your job is very easy
and you can not only deny mr depp's
claim but you can fight for amber on her
counter claim and it's interesting that
miss vasquez just changed their theory
after six weeks she said
oh well domestic abuse just means
physical abuse
that's not what mr depp said
it's not what dr curry said
it's not what dr hughes said
it's not what you know to be true you
know that the evidence that you've seen
constitutes all sorts of abuse and
there's a reason that they're running as
fast as they can from those sorts of
abuse because they know that he did it
now the suggestion that amber's abuse
allegations are a hoax is vicious and
vile
mr depp can say whatever he wants now
but he can't say change the evidence
that you've seen at the trial
the evidence shows that misheard did not
commit abuse hoaxes not about sexual
violence not about may 21 2016 and
certainly not about mr depp and mr
waldman's catch-all all-purpose
statement that miss herds abuse hoax
which suggests that every one of her
allegations are false
but that's coming to an end
the evidence shows she did not commit
any of those hoaxes
the evidence shows that she was abused
exactly how not only she but her
witnesses
supporting her claims say that she was
and their witnesses even who claim that
mr depp abused her
mrs vasquez talked about actual malice
she says because mr waldman was acting
as mr depp's agent you have to look at
mr waldman they're standing in the shoes
of one another and as mr depp's agent mr
depp's malice is mr waldman's malice
mr depp's walden alice is mr waldman's
malice
he acted with actual malice when he made
these statements
now after years and years of mr depp
controlling the roles that miss heard
took miss heard had the biggest hit of
her career three months
before she was sued
she had withstood
mr depp's attempt to have her fired from
aquaman
and his own jealousy as his career went
down the drain before her op-ed for
reasons having nothing to do with
misheard
but once the lawsuit against mrs heard
was filed
his campaign that he promised to destroy
her entered a new face
and then it reached a crescendo when mr
depp and mr waldman decided to meet with
the daily mail together and decide to
plant statements that were defamatory of
misheard
in the spring of 2020 leading up to the
uk trial
you've heard amber and her agent jessica
kovacevich talk about the impact to
amber's career she can't get hired
because of the negative treatment she
gets studios like her
co-stars like her she tests well
but she can't get opportunities because
of the negativity associated with mr
depp and mr waldman
you heard
amber heard
on the stand yesterday
telling you exactly
what she has experienced as a result of
mr depp's promise to bring her global
humiliation
that promise
to to paraphrase catherine arnold
this hurts damages expert that promise
was a spark
and that promise he kept
because he had told her again and again
the only way out of this is death and
when she chose a different path out of
it
he decided to make that promise
he decided
to throw that spark
and when mr waldman became involved that
spark became a forest fire
that forest fire has continued to this
day
we ask ladies and gentlemen that you
hold mr depp accountable for his actions
stand up for victims of domestic abuse
everywhere who suffer in silence
stand up
for the freedom of speech
the freedom to speak about your life
that the first amendment protects
give amber heard her voice back
give amber heard her life back
thank you so much for your service on
this jury
thank you mr ruttenborn
members of the jury this is an important
case to both the plaintiff and the
defendant
in order to reach a verdict each of you
must agree on that verdict in other
words your verdict must be unanimous
the first thing you should do when you
go back to the jury room is to select a
presiding juror the role of the
presiding juror is to see to it that the
deliberations are conducted in an
orderly and business-like manner that
they are conducted only in the jury room
when all the members of the jury are
present and that each juror has the
opportunity to fully and fairly express
his or her views
it is rarely helpful for jurors upon
first entering the jury room to take a
straw vote or for any juror to make an
emphatic expression of his or her
opinion in the case or to announce a
determination to stand for a certain
verdict to do so before all jurors have
had an opportunity to consult with one
another and exchange views and opinions
might allow your sense of pride to
prevent you from retreating from an
announced position even when shown that
such position is unsound
you have a duty to consult with one
another and to deliberate with the
objective of reaching an agreement if it
can be done without offending your
individual judgment each of you must
decide this case for yourself but only
after an impartial consideration of the
evidence with your fellow jurors
in the course of deliberation a juror
should not hesitate to re-examine his or
her abuse and change his or her opinion
if convinced it is an error
however none of you should surrender
your honest conviction as to the weight
or effect of the evidence solely because
of the opinion of your fellow jurors or
for the mere purpose of returning a
verdict
in the jury room you will have the
exhibits that were entered into evidence
you also have the instructions of law
that i just read to you and you will
have the the verdict forms
you'll also have
a laptop and that laptop will have
just two files on it and deputy lucio
will set it up for you in the jury room
one is the plaintiff's files for audio
and video files and one is the
defendant's files for audio and video
files and you'll be able to hear and
watch those as well
the ones that were submitted into
evidence during your deliberations until
you are discharged from jury service you
must not communicate with or provide any
information to anyone who is not a
member of this jury by any means about
this case you may not use any electronic
device or media to conduct any
independent research about this case the
legal or factual issues in the case and
the individuals or attorneys involved in
the case you are not permitted to
consult dictionaries or reference
materials search the internet visit
websites or blogs or use any other tools
to obtain information about this case or
to help you decide the case do not try
to find out information from any source
outside of the testimony and the
exhibits received as evidenced during
the trial you will also have i know the
attorneys discuss briefly about the
verdict forms you'll have two sets of
verdict forms one for the
one for mr depp's case and one for ms
heard's case okay now when you have
these verdict forms the first three
pages of both verdict forms have each of
the statements separately okay so when
you're going through it you're going to
to to look at each statement separately
and answer the questions that are on the
page okay now if you come to
if you decide yes for every question
for a statement then that's when you go
to the last page of the uh
verdict form
which is for damages so for example if
you find yes for all of statement one uh
then you would you could go to four and
five for damages if you
find yes for all of statement one and
statement two you can you still go to
four and five for damages if you say yes
for statement one statement two and
statement three you obviously go to four
and five for damages if you answer no on
any of the pages for any of the
statements you don't go to four and five
okay so that will be for all of them and
when you're when you do come to a
verdict make sure the four person signs
it and dates it and then just let the
deputy know about that okay
all right now for the tough part um
you may remember at the beginning of
this case
i told you we would randomly select four
people to be the alternates okay
we still have two alternates left
and the numbers were placed in the
envelope in the very beginning
of the case so let me just say before i
release the alternates that i know that
this trial has been a huge sacrifice for
all of you
and i have taken uh and you've taken
taken away from your life uh for weeks
on end here and i know i speak for all
of us associated with the case and i
want to thank you for your service in
this matter
i know how hard it is to come this far
and then not get a chance to deliberate
but that does not lessen the respect and
admiration that we have for you as an
alternate you will not deliberate but
you are still under order of this court
not to do any outside research in this
case or to talk to anyone about this
case at this time and you're still under
your oath as a juror that is because if
something happens to a juror during
deliberations i will call you back for
service and you will join the
deliberations and they'll start again
and you'll be part of the jury so you
are under these restrictions and your
oath until a verdict is reached we will
contact you once this has occurred and
then you'll be free from your
obligations okay but again thank you for
your service all right so in this matter
the alternate jurors are juror number
three and 14.
all right
so
at this time uh
those jurors are excused and also the
remaining jurors can retire now to the
jury room to begin their deliberations
okay so thank you all
okay
so it'll always be at the top of the
hour so for example if i get the verdict
at 10 20 in the morning
it wouldn't be read until noon so it's
always going to be the top of the hour
at least 60 minutes later that makes
sense that gives you time i would ask
that at least one attorney is close
enough within a 10-minute range for any
questions i'd appreciate that okay um
and i know some of the attorneys aren't
going to be leaving so i just wanted to
thank all of you for your
professionalism and your hard work
during this case it's much easier being
a judge when you have excellent trial
attorneys in front of you it does make
it easier and i also want to thank the
attorneys and litigants for the kindness
and the great demeanor you've shown to
my staff and to the courthouse staff and
to the deputies in the sheriff's
department i really appreciate it it
means means a great deal to me okay and
i also appreciate judy because she's a
rock star okay so
yes yes thank you
well that's the first okay
all right that is one thing on which mrs
peterhoft and we respectfully disagree
agree completely
completely agree well well good i'm glad
on the last day we finally have an
agreement thank you ryan we're very
grateful thank you
you want to approach
you